GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU FOR
ATTENDING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE MY
NAME IS LIEUTENANT GONZALEZ I AM
THE CHAIR IS LIKE COMMITTEE.
THEIR AGENDA IS --
BACKGROUND DOCUMENTS AND SIGN IN
SHEETS IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM.
THE HEARING IS MEAN I LIVE
STREAMED WITH CLOSED CAPTIONING
TRANSLATION SERVICES ARE DEVICES
FOR SPANISH SPEAKERS ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE BACK OF THE
ROOM AS WELL.
WHAT HAVE A PERIOD OF OUR MEMBER
DISCUSSION AFTER EACH PANEL A
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL TAKE PLACE
AFTER THE [INAUDIBLE]
CAN'T.
I LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
MEMBERS THAT HAVE JOINED US
TODAY IT'S GREAT TO HAVE.
FOLKS COME DURING THEIR SO WHO
IS THE GREAT.
TIME I KNOW ON HER WAY IS AND
WHAT THE MEMBERS SELECT
COMMITTEE ELOISE RADIUS WE HAVE
SELECT COMMITTEE MEMBER MONIQUE
LIMON HERE THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CECILIA
AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHARON QUIRK SILVA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JESSE GABRIEL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS THE BOSS AND I'D
LIKE TO ESPECIALLY THANK AND
RECOGNIZE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIGUEL SANTIAGO WHOSE DISTRICT
WE ARE IN TODAY AND GO AHEAD AND
ASK.
YOU LIKE TO WELCOME US.
YES THANK YOU I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING ALL OUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING TODAY --
ESPECIALLY ON THIS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE AND PARTICULARLY ALL
THE ON WORKERS --
WILL COME HERE DAVID TODAY TO
PARTICIPATE.
I THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT THAT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
FACT.
I'M WE TOOK A LOOK AT THE
WORKFORCE IN THE UNITED STATES A
57% OF BEING WOMEN.
WE WILL KNOW NATIONALLY AT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE THAT WE
SPARKED UP A SERIOUS DEBATE.
ABOUT THE WORKFORCE A SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND THE THE NECESITO
ELIMINATED AND HAVE ZERO
TOLERANCE APPROACH.
I THINK ANY SORT OF VIOLENCE OR
THREATS EITHER HAPPEN TO WOMEN.
OR ANYONE REALLY AT THE
WORKPLACE.
I KNOW WHAT SHOULD WE AYE FACE
RETALIATION I JUST FOR DEMANDING
JUSTICE OUT WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
WRONGED.
THIS IS IN PART DISCUSSION OF
ONE PROUD TO BE HERE A WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- IT'S
GONZALEZ FLETCHER FOR LEADING
THE SEPARATE.
SO THANK YOU AND I AM.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE FROM
EARLY ON WHEN THE MEAT TO
MOVEMENT STARTED WE KNEW THAT I
IT WAS GREAT THAT PEOPLE ARE
FINALLY SPEAK.
AND THAT IT AT THE TIME HAD COME
IN REALLY BEYOND THE TIME HAD
COME.
WHEN THIS ISSUE HAD TO BE I
BROUGHT TO LIGHT?
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT AND THERE
ARE THERE ARE WOMEN IN
PROFESSIONS THAT.
HAVE IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TIME
TO EVEN SPEAK UP THAT MCCARTY
FACE RETALIATION.
THAT HAVE FACED --
CRAFTSMAN THE WORKPLACE IN WAYS
THAT WE CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE.
THIS STARTED I'VE SO LONG AGO I
THINK WITH.
IN ARE OFFICE WHEN WE STARTED
HEARING ABOUT HOW THE SITUATION
WITH RATE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT IN
OUR OUR JANITORIAL WORKERS IN
AND A FEW YEARS AGO BEFORE ME TO
WE THINK ABOUT STAFF.
AND WE STARTED THIS ROAD
TOGETHER AND KNOWING THAT SO
MANY OF OUR WORKERS SPECIES
ISSUES BUT IT TOOK --
A LOT OF HOLLYWOOD IN THE
LEGISLATURE I'VE FOR PEOPLE. TO
TO START PAYING ATTENTION SO I
I'M GLAD THAT WE CAN BE HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT NOT ONLY --
WHAT REAL WORKERS FACE?
MOVEMENT OR OR THIS DESIRE TO
STAND UP FOR THEMSELVES TO STAND
UP FOR THEIR GOD GIVEN RIGHTS
THEIR RIGHTS IN THE WORKPLACE.
I'M BUT ALSO THE RETALIATION
THAT.
RESULT OF THAT WHAT WE DO TO FIX
THAT SO I'M.
WE'RE GONNA START AND BEFORE I
BEGIN I'D LIKE.
TO OPEN UP TO THE MEMBERS ON
THAT THAT ARE HERE TO TO RECEIVE
TESTIMONY IF YOU WANT TO SAY A
COUPLE WORDS I YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BY ANY MEANS.
I HAVE A QUESTION ANSWER PERIOD
BUT IF I'D LIKE TO OPEN UP THAT
OPERA.
HE WOULD LIKE.
GOOD GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
CECILIA AGUIAR-CURRY I'M FROM
DISTRICT FOUR I'M FAR AWAY FROM
LOS ANGELES I REPRESENT SEVEN
COUNTIES IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
PRIMARY OUT AGRICULTURE AND SO
I'M QUITE INTERESTED IN FINDING
OUT AND LISTEN TO ALL THE
WORKERS THE AND THE PRESENTERS
TODAY.
AND WHAT THE ISSUES ARE SO THE
WHEN I GO BACK I CAN HELP
SUPPORT OTHERS IN MY IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON MAKING GOOD
DECISIONS FOR YOU.
SO THANK YOU FOR INCLUDING ME
TODAY.
A GOOD EVENING I AM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHARON QUIRK SILVA
REPRESENTING NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
NOW I'M REALLY.
HAPPY TO BE HERE NOT BECAUSE OF
THE TOPIC BUT BECAUSE OF THE
SERIOUSNESS OF IT --
I WILL SAY THAT --
EVER SINCE WE HAVE BEEN THROUGH
THE STATE ASSEMBLY MUCH HEARING
MORE AND MORE NOT ONLY ABOUT OUR
ISSUES WITH SEXUAL ASSAULT WITH
THE MEAT TO MEMBER.
IT'S MADE ME PERSONALLY MUCH
MORE AWARE AND AS I HAD SEVERAL
UNITE HERE MEMBERS COME TO VISIT
ME IN THE STATE CAPITOL IN THEM
REALLY.
PLAYING SOME OF THE SCENARIOS
THAT THEY ARE AND IT'S MADE ME
MUCH MORE AWARE.
EAT WHAT I GOT ANY HOTELS SO
JUST LAST WEEK I WAS AT A HOTEL
OF IT WAS ACTUALLY NOT A WILL
TELL BUT A VERY --
LARGE CORPORATE BUILDING AN ICE
WATCHED ONE OF THE OLDER WOMEN
WHO WAS DOING HER WORK WITH --
TO IF YOU WANT TO CALL ON THAT
TRASH.
CONTAINERS TRYING TO CARRY THAT
AND ANOTHER BUCKET GOAL TRYING
TO GET IN AND OUT OF THE
ELEVATOR.
AND IT JUST.
PUT IN THE SETTING OF HELL OF
THE I THINK RELEVANT THIS
CONVERSATION IS GOING TO BE
BECAUSE OF EVERYTHING FROM HER
AGE TO THAT MATERIAL SHE WAS
CARING.
HOW OF THE FORMER RULE SHE COULD
BE SO I'M REALLY --
WANTING TO MAKE SURE ANYTHING WE
HERE WE CAN DO SOMETHING ABOUT.
WHAT DOES THAT AT THIS TIME
MONIQUE LIMON I REPRESENT
INSURANCE OUT OF OUR COUNTIES
GLAD TO BE HERE THANK YOU CHAIR --
FOR GATHERING ES AND THINK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AT FOR
HOSTING US THE DISTRICT AS
SOMEONE WHO SPENDS AT FOURTEEN
YEARS WORKING IN HIGHER ED.
AND AND DESPITE KNOWING THAT WE
HAD OFFICES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
OFFICES AND ON BITS INDIVIDUALS
AND KNOWING THAT EVERY DAY
SOMEONE I'M IN THE WORKFORCE IN
HIGHER AND EXPERIENCE DIFFERENT
ISSUES.
OUT REPRESENTED OR NOT AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE HERE
AND TO HEAR YOUR VOICES ON AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
ELEVATE YOUR VOICES AT THE STATE
LEVEL THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS LUIS RIVAS AND
I REPRESENT THE THIRTY NINTH
DISTRICT WHICH IS THAT HE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY --
IN LA I AM EXCITED TO BE HERE --
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT YOUR STORIES
IN HERE --
PANELISTS --
STORIES ESPECIALLY I'VE YOU KNOW
I COME FROM THE FIELD THAT.
IT WAS PREDOMINANTLY MEN I WAS
AN ENGINEER SO THERE'S A LOT OF
ISSUES IN IN TECHNOLOGY WOMEN IN
SCIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE HE WHERE --
AND SO I THINK --
YOUR SEXUAL HARASSMENT HAS.
UNFORTUNATELY BEEN SOME HAS
HAPPENED IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES RIGHT NOT JUST
POLITICS OR ENTERTAINMENT I'M SO
I'M GLAD TO BE HERE TODAY.
UP TO LEARN ABOUT THIS HOW IT IS
AFFECTED --
THIS INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
SORT ASSEMBLY SILOS GOMEZ VALUES
OF SOME BUT NOT THE NORM.
I REPRESENTS A WORKING CLASS
AREA AND I SOON THEIR
TEMPERATURES.
IT'S IT'S MY HONOR TO BE HERE
AND I THINK --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOADED
THEMSELVES FLETCHER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP.
IN PUTTING NOT ONLY THE
COMMITTEE TOGETHER BUT ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS SUCH AS
TODAY.
I'M HONORED TO BE ONE OF THE
MEMBERS.
I HAVE BEEN A WORKERS
COMPENSATION ATTORNEY FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS REPRESENTING INJURED
WORKERS.
MANY OF THOSE ARE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO WERE.
SUBJECT OF HARASSMENT AND ABUSE.
BECAUSE OF THEIR POSITION.
AND I WAS ALWAYS VERY PROUD OF
THE FACT THAT THEY WOULD STAND
UP.
AND FIGHT FOR THEIR RIGHTS.
BECAUSE WHEN THEY DID THAT
EVERYBODY WHO CAME AFTER THEM
KNEW THAT THEY WOULD BE HEARD
AND THEIR THEIR RIGHTS WOULD BE
PROTECTED.
BEING HERE TODAY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT NOT FOR WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO SHARE WITH YOU.
BUT FOR WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SHARE WITH US WE NEED TO GATHER
THIS INFORMATION SO THAT AS WE
CONTINUE WITH THE POLICY MAKING.
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHO IT IS WE ARE
TRYING TO PROTECT WE KNOW THE
ACTIONS THAT WERE TRYING TO
PROTECT SO I THINK ALL OF YOU
FOR BEING HERE TO OUR PANELISTS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING THE VOICE
THAT WE NEED TO HEAR.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY NAME
IS JESSE GABRIEL I REPRESENT THE
FORTY FIFTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHICH THE WEST SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY.
I JUST ABOUT AN HOUR AWAY FROM
HERE I AM REALLY PLEASED TO BE
HERE THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR FOR
THE INVITATION AND TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO FOR HOSTING US.
THIS IS MY FIRST SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARING I THINK I FELT
IT WAS IMPORTANT BE HERE BECAUSE
I THINK THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC --
IN I AM LOOKING FORWARD --
TO UNDER THE HEARING FROM OUR
OUR OUR PANELISTS TODAY TO
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THIS ISSUE
TO UNDERSTANDING HOW ARE WE AND
I CAN BE A CONSTRUCTIVE IN
ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES AND FELT
LIKE THIS WAS AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO BROADEN THE
CONVERSATION IN HERE FROM SOME
VOICES THAT WE DON'T.
ALWAYS HEAR FROM AS WE'VE
THINKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES SO
REALLY REALLY PLEASED TO BE HERE
AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH ALL
OF YOU.
THANK YOU KNOW.
I'M WITHOUT I DO I'D BE REMISS
TO NOT THINK --
YOU MIGHT HEAR LOCAL ELEVEN FOR
OCARINAS THIS SPACE IN ORDER TO
HAVE A SUPPORT DISCUSSION AND SO
MANY OF THE STORIES THAT COME.
THE WOMEN WHO WHO WORK AT LOCAL
OUR WORK.
IN A FIELD IN A REPRESENTED BY A
BY -- UNITE
HERE LOCAL AND SO WITH THAT WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IS THAT THE
SPEAKERS SPEAK FOR ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES WE HAVE A TIME KEEPER
WILL TELL YOU WHEN YOU'RE
RUNNING OUT OF TIME SHE'S RIGHT
THERE.
I'M SO WE WE WANT TO KEEP THAT
THE STORIES TO FIVE MINUTES SO
THAT WE CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND IT --
YOU CAN SPEAK IN SPANISH OR
ENGLISH WHERE I THINK.
ALMOST ALL OF US [INAUDIBLE]
UNDERSTANDABLE.
YEAH WERE PRETTY GOOD.
PAM.
AND THAT WE'RE GONNA WANNA AT
YOU CAN START IT WILL JUST WE'LL
JUST GO DOWN THE LINE AND YOU
CAN TELL US --
WHAT YOUR JOB IS A GAS AND --
ME NUMBNESS WON THE MILADA HE IF
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS WITH KNOW
THAT IT UP OR THINK IT THIS TIME
YOUNG'S.
A THOUGHT THE ONLY THAT HE
OVERHANG IN LEVEL BEEN WITH AND
THE LONG BEACH.
GO AHEAD AND TELL US YOUR STORY
OKAY.
I'M THE HOUSEKEEPER.
IN A HOTEL LOBBIES THIS PAST
DECEMBER I WAS HONORED TO BE
INVITED WITH OR THAT IT KOREA'S
CHOSE.
WOMAN INCLUDING SANDRA HERE.
FROM THE TOWN THAT.
US ONE OF THAT SILENCE BREAK IT
THEM AT THAT TIME MY THAT'S SEEN
ME PERSON OF THE YEAR.
THEN GOT VERY SAD RETHOUGHT THAT
SEVERAL UP OR THE SUN IS VERY
GREAT THERE'S WHERE WE'LL TELL
WORKERS.
THE HOTEL INDUSTRY CAN'T BE AT
THE END YOU KNOW SPRAYS WOMAN'S
TO WORK.
EACH THEY HAVE HOUSEKEEPERS INTO
OUT WRONG TO CLEAN IT.
SHE THAT THING LOW WHO WERE
BEING SIGN.
BEING ON THE LONG IN THAT ROOM
WE NOT COMPLETE STRANGER.
WILL MAKE ANY WHILE ACOSTA BLOOM.
BOWING YOU KNOW OUT BROWN.
THAT HORRIBLE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED TO YOU. TO YOUR
COWORKER OR A FEW SO WHY VERY
VERY SCARY.
THESE SAFETY ISSUES I RIO.
AND HOW MUCH SALAS WHO YES THEY
HAVE MORE THAN A FEW TIMES.
BUT THE LARGER PROGRAM THAT MANY
WOMEN.
THAT WORK IN THE HOTEL INDUSTRY.
DO NOT HAVE A VOICE AT ALL.
WHEN THEY EXPERIENCE ON TEAM BEN?
THEY ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK OUT.
YOU CANNOT READ SOME
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU [INAUDIBLE]
I MEAN.
WENT THEY THREE IF SOMETHING BAD
THEY ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK OUT
BECAUSE THEY MIGHT BE BRINGING.
IF YOU ARE THEN EMAIL WORKER OR
A SINGLE MOTHER.
THE WE ITS LOOSING MY JOB.
THAT FEAR SILENCE HAS SONG MAYBE
WOMAN SIGN THOUGH.
AND THE WHOLE TELLING THIS.
THREE BODY FAT MAN NEEDS TO BE
THIS WAY.
A FEW YEARS AGO MY COWORKERS IN.
NINETY FIVE THE FORMAT YOU IN
THE ON THOUGHT THAT WILL HAVE A
VOICE IN OUTLETS HAVE.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT [INAUDIBLE]
WE FACING.
WE WAS NOT EASY BECAUSE I WOULD
THAT A KID SHOW WE WERE ABLE TO
WIN.
WE SAW ME WE FIND THE LAST OUR
FIRST NEW CONTRACT.
AT THAT LISTING ALONENESS.
IN I AM VERY VERY LOW. TO SAY
THAT IT IS FOR BOTH HIM AND
THOUGHT THAT CALIFORNIA TO
AREN'T WE YOU PASSED THE POD THE
BUTTONS.
IF YOU KNOW.
THE OLD MORE.
WHERE WHERE WHERE MY FRIENDS
SANDRA?
WHAT WORKS BECAUSE SHE WORKED
THERE?
ABOUT TERRA MAN.
DO NOT HAVE A VOICE [INAUDIBLE]
IN.
THINK CANNOT SPEAK UP OP OUR
PROVINCE.
THEY FACE WITHOUT FEAR OF
RETALIATION.
I URGE YOU.
I URGE YOU TO WITH STAND WITH
WHAT IF A GAME OF YOU WITH.
IMPOSSIBLE LET'S SEE IF.
THAT WOULD PRO THANKS BORN THE
POLL WORKERS.
BUT I'M NOT BUT I ALSO HEARD YOU
LIST THEM WE WORK IN LIKE THOSE
FIVE THAT'S SHOWING THEM.
WHO ARE FIGHTING TO HAVE A VOICE
IN THEIR JOB? TO SAY THAT WE CAN
MEET UP WITH HIM MEANS.
TO A BETTER PLACE TO WORK
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU --
NAM ME NUMBER.
SUMMED UP THE SKINNER --
DOT HIT BUT AT THAT ANYA.
COME ON UP BLOCK THOSE.
MAYBE THEY'LL NOT HIMSELF.
DEMOCRATS AND GOOD EVENING MY
NAME IS SOME NAPA SCANNED THAT
AND I WORKED AT THE TYRANNY OF
RESORT I WAS ED DISHWASHER AT
THE TERRY NAY ADDRESS STAFFING
AGENCY --
MUSIC BUT WE SORT OF NAPA FULL
SETS ONE MAIN THING --
AT BEST YOU'RE NOT BY ME --
BUT I QUE IF WHAT I SOME I THINK --
MATHIS YOUR WHICH OF COURSE US.
IT WILL I LISTEN MORE THEY THEY
THEY CAN A MENACE AND THE GOSPEL.
THAT ON THE ME THAT THIS YOUNG
NOT.
IS THEY MAY THIS CONSOLE --
WHAT WE HAVE LIKE THE MORE?
NOT AS YET ANOTHER ASPECT --
THE MEN I DON'T THINK.
THEY YEAH.
PLUS CONSEQUENCE US GET SOME
YEAH.
GIVE ME LOUDEST ON SAT SOON
AFTER I WHERE I STARTED WORKING
AT THE CHARITY A RESORT --
AYE MY MALE SUPERVISOR TRIED TO
PRESSURE ME TO BE HIS LOVER.
AND EVEN TRIED TO KISS ME AT
WORK.
IT WAS ONE OF THE WORST
EXPERIENCES OF MY LIFE.
I TRY TO REFUSE I HAD HIS
ADVANCES AND HE RETALIATED
AGAINST ME BY TAKING ME OFF THE
SCHEDULE.
I FINALLY FOUND THE COURAGE TO
COMPLAIN TO TEAR NAM MANAGEMENT.
BUT NOT LONG AFTER I COMPLAINED
I WAS FIRED.
THIS WHISKEY --
I BELIEVE IN --
THAT I NOW KNOW SAY NOT SICK IS
ALSO RESPONSIBLY LOOK ABBAS
OBLIGATE.
JOEY AND RISK BUT WE SUCKED OUT
HOW MOST.
BUT I CAN STEP.
SO IN THE CITY ARE LESS BOND
SILENCE.
MAY THIS --
MAY THIS BE VIETNAM BECAUSE WITH
GOVERNMENT.
I AFTER I SPOKE AL.
THAT COMPANY DID NOT WANT TO
TAKE RESPONSE.
I'M AND I WAS I WAS FIRED --
NO SUBSTANCE IN THE EIGHTIES SO
MOST GO MORE THAT I HAVE NOTICED
THEY SAY WILL NOT COME.
BECAUSE THE PLACE IS A MORE NOT
THAN THE MOST BUSTLING PEOPLE
CALL IS THE BY LINE SO MUST OUR
HOTTEST BUT I JUST DON'T KNOW
WHEN I'M.
ABOUT THE HOLIDAYS.
IT'S ALMOST NOT A THE COMPANY
MAKES US FEEL LIKE WE'RE BIRTH
PLACE.
LIKE WE'RE JUST THERE LIKE WHERE
WE DON'T NEED ANY.
MEDEA OUT TO THEM NOW THEM ON
THAT POINT OUT THAT AND YEAH IT
SAID.
AS THE ONLY --
BUT HE'S THE OUT WE GO SEPARATE
BROUGHT US FOR SOME ASKING THAT
WE GOT ON THIS.
GET MAKE THEY GET ON THE GOOD
THAT WE DON'T BUT I SEAT ONE OF
THEM ON THAT ALL.
ALL NAPA SENATE BALK AT THAT ON
THE AND I'LL SEE IF.
I GOT ALL MY SAYS THAT S. ONE
SIDE.
I FILED A LAWSUIT AGAINST
CARRIED ANNA AND THE STAFFING
AGENCY.
I'M IN I'M REALLY GRATEFUL I AM
THAT I HAD THE COURAGE TO KEEP
GOING ON AND TO PURSUE MY
LAWSUIT.
I'M SO THAT TERRY AT COULD BE
READ AS A KID I CLAIM
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHAT HAPPENED
TO ME -- HE
YES THEY MUST WITH CLOSE UP LOOK
AT THAT YET BUT ACADEMIC I AM
BUT A SEAT OUT ON THE PORCH Y.
LAS TO SEE MOST BUS ON THE BOOK.
WHAT ELECT ALSO GAY AND GET SOME
OF SOME OF OUR STATE THE HOME?
YEAH CAN STEP THEN THE MOST.
THAT I TOLD.
YEAH AT THAT IS THAT I LAID.
IS THE SECOND A LOT AND I WON
SALAS.
YET I ASSEMBLY QUE SE.
GET WHAT THEY CAN MIMIC IT WILL
GET BUT OUT HOPE KEVIN WOULDN'T
JUST PERSONAS.
IN THIS IS THE MOST FLA.
WE GOT YES.
I'M PROUD THAT I CAN CONTINUE TO
BE AN ADVOCATE --
ON BEHALF OF OTHER WOMEN ON
ESPECIALLY ON BEHALF OF WOMEN
WHO WORKERS [INAUDIBLE]
AGENCY --
UNFAIR AND THAT'S WHY I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THE BILL LOADED UP
A GONZALEZ FLETCHER HAS WRITTEN
A WILL HELP SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
AND IT WILL MAKE THEM ME COMPANY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
WORKERS WILL WORK FOR THE
AGENCIES ARE NOT SEXUALLY
HARASSED.
WE NEED LAWS LIKE THIS TO
PROTECT US THINK YELL.
WHEN?
YOU NOBODY'S SOME OF IT I EVEN --
SO YUMMY THOUGHT THAT YOU ESTO
DOUBLE THE OF WATER YES YOU'RE
TRYING YIELDS.
IT SO YOU WILL NOT SOLVE
ANYTHING SO THEY BEGIN THEY
THEY'VE GOT US YOUNG SIX WIDELY
CONSIDERED I HOPE.
I GIVING IT A WHAT DID MY LAMB
[INAUDIBLE]
HE BEEN YEAH.
HOW THE F. AGREE THAT WHAT THE
MODEL WE SMOKE?
GOOD EVENING I'M MY NAME IS ANNA --
AND I AM A WORKER WITH THE U. S.
W..
I AND I WAVE PLAY BEAT THE MONEY
GET US ON SIX ONE IN US YOU
GOTTA GO OUT [INAUDIBLE]
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
IT BE NIKOLAI YOU'LL SEE ONLINE
HAVE MEANT THEM ABOUT A LOBBYIST
WAS AND WHAT THEY MIGHT HAVE
BEEN YAK.
THE BUS TO MEET THE CYNICAL WHEN
I DON'T FEEL THAT THEY HAVE A
HOT FOR ME SEE COURTS.
I CAME FROM I IMMIGRATED FROM
WHAT THE MIND THAT BECAUSE MY
HUSBAND WAS MURDERED ON AND I HE
GAY A FOR FIGHT THAT MTV Ó MOM.
ORDER BUT THAT AWARENESS THAT
PULLS.
WAY BEAT THE AMOUNT.
HE I MEAN FAMILY MEANT THEY NOT
THEY MAY HAVE LOST ME WHAT.
DO DAM I AM DUE TO MY LIMITED
ENGLISH AND MY IMMIGRATION
STATUS -- I
DIDN'T HAVE MANY RESOURCES
AVAILABLE [INAUDIBLE]
IT.
YOU HAVE YOUR LET'S THE
UNDEFEATED BICU I MEANT THAN
THOSE THAT ARE HOLDS IT AT THE
MALL EYEGLASSES BOOK IT IS THAT
I HAD PUT UP THE STEEP CLIFFS.
THEY GET IS THE THIS SEE I LOVE.
IT BUSTED UP ANOTHER UP WE ARE
GOING TO LET ME.
E. INTERNAL ME SMALL E. AMERICAN
ABOUT LACK OF YET I HAVE ON THIS
THIS EGO THING WHAT THE MODEL.
EVEN IF IT IS I DON'T KNOW I PUT
IT.
NOT FOR THE YEAH.
FELLOW THE OTHER IS THE AYE
MONNING S. AMOUNTS THAT ALTHOUGH
YEAH WELL BROUGHT UP THAT.
YOU'LL MEET ANNOYED AT THE END
LONG AGO SCENE BECAUSE IT NOT
EVEN BOTHER.
TO GET.
IT IMPACTS YEAH YOU PUT YOUR I
MEAN LOOK AT THE END THIS
BELIEVE THAT BUT I HOPE.
THE IT ALL.
BILLION BE UP WHETHER THEY SEE
THEY GAVE.
WE BEAT THE NOT THE BC NOT ARGUE
THAT.
BETTER THAN I THOUGHT WILL GIVE
WAY THIS NEED GAP US ALL OF THE
LOS ANGELES MIDDLE YOU LATIN BUT
ANOTHER [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
SALAS ENOUGH SUPPLE YONG'S SO A
PROMO TORA <U&gt;&LT;C.GREEN&GT; HE MADE WAS&LT;/C&GT;</U&gt;
THAT THAT WOULD CHECK IT ALSO
EAT A LOT DONE BEFORE ME SEE HAS
THAT POLICY HAS.
BEEN ABOUT WHAT ABOUT THE WHOLE
THING.
I PARTICIPATED IN A STRIKE AND
I'M IN I'M REALLY THANKFUL FOR
THE SUPPORT THAT I CHAIR
GONZALEZ FLETCHER HAS GIVEN US.
HE GAVE US THE EDICT IT THE NAME
ON MY WAY OUT OF IT IS YOU MY
SET THEN THANK YOU ALSO IS.
IF ON A PERFECT NO THE MOST YOU
KNOW THAT THAT I HOPE TO GET OUT
IN THAT AND I'M IAN THOUGHTS.
LIKE THEY HAVE IT IT'S NEVER
BEEN THANK [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH WATERGATE.
IF I'M AND I LEFT WITHOUT
PRODUCTS THEY EAT YOU'VE
CHARITIES HAVE IT YEAH MOMENTOUS
THAT I'M IT IS ENORMOUS TODAY
IT'S NOT REALLY THAT GAVE YOU
THE MOST HE GAVE.
THEM A MORSEL NOT ONCE GET AND
ONCE THEY EAT OUT A LOT THE
WATER.
I GET UP AT FIVE P. M. ENDING IF
I DON'T OUT LOUD.
SEEING INCIDENTS FEEL IDLING.
I DON'T BUY ME SAYS HE LEADS
FEEL.
AND SO --
RIGHT NOW CURRENTLY WE'RE
WORKING ON THE SECOND PART OF
THE BILL WHICH IS AB.
TWENTY SEVENTY NINE WHICH IS
CONTINUING THE WORK THAT --
WE HAVE ALREADY STARTED DOING
WITH A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WHICH IS CREATING THAT
SPACE FOR WOMEN. TO KEEP WORKING
AND AND HELPING OF WILL HAVE A
GROUP YOU HAVE A GROUP OF FROM A
THOUGHT AS WE GO TO TRAIN OF
THEIR THEIR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
NOT ONLY WOMEN BUT TRAIN THEM.
ON ON THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
HOW TO SPEAK UP IN THE WORKPLACE.
IT SAYS TO ME GET NOTHING I'M UP
A YOUNG BALK MEDEVAC AIMLESSLY
AND ALL LA MAS AND THEN I'M IN
BOTH STATE ABLE TO YOU KNOW
THINK OF THAT.
IF NOTHING ELSE WE WANT TO HOLD
MORE TREATMENT.
WHEN TO CONTINUE TO HOLD MORE
TRAINING IN THE WORKPLACE IS?
MY NAME IS TINEA PALMER.
AND I WORKED AT THE JW MARRIOTT
AMERICO IN SANTA MONICA. FOR
ALMOST A YEAR AS A HOSTESS.
AT THE RESTAURANT.
WHILE I WORKED AT THE HOSPITAL
OR AT THE HOTEL.
I BOTH EXPERIENCED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
AND WITNESSED THE IMPACTS OF
DISPARAGEMENT.
WHEN AN INSTANCE OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT WAS REPORTED?
AMERIGO IS OPERATED BY COLUMBIA
SUSSEX.
A COMPANY WHICH HAS FACED
ALLEGATIONS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND MULTIPLE HOTELS.
IT OPERATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I BELIEVE THAT IF.
WORKERS ARE UNABLE.
TO FEEL SAFE OPERATING SUCH A
REPORTER AND PRAYER --
I BELIEVE THAT IT WORKERS ARE
UNABLE TO FEEL SAFE.
WHEN REPORTING --
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THE HAS WITH TILL THE
HOSPITALITY CULTURE.
WILL NEVER CHANGE.
AT THE LEMERRE GO.
IT WAS NORMAL TO JOKE AROUND
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
WHEN TIME ASSISTANT OF THE
ASSISTANT FOOD AND BEVERAGE
MANAGER MARK TONG?
MADE AN EXPLICIT JOKE TO ME.
AND THE SERVER.
NAME JAMES.
ABOUT MY CO WORKERS HIGH.
SAYING HE ONLY DEEDS GROWTH
CENTER THAT HIGH BECAUSE IT'S
EASIER ACCESS TO HIS PRIVATE
AREA.
I WAS SHOCKED.
THAT A COMMENT LIKE THIS WOULD
MAKE.
IT WOULD COME FROM AN ASSISTANT
MANAGER.
WHEN ONE OF MY MALE CO WORKERS
BEGAN TO MAKE ON UNWANTED
ADVANCEMENTS TOWARDS ME I DO
FEEL LIKE I MANAGER WHO?
WOULD JOKE ABOUT WOMEN.
WOULD MAKE --
WOULD TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND I
FEARED --
THE POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF
SPEAKING OUT.
THIS ISN'T IT THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT HAS IMPACTED GENERATIONS A
HOTEL HOUSEKEEPERS.
WHEN MY GRANDMOTHER?
BUT WHEN MY GRANDMOTHER
IMMIGRATED FROM THE UNITED A TO
THE UNITED STATES FROM THAILAND.
SHE WORKED AS A HOUSEKEEPER AT A
SMALL MOTEL.
IN KANSAS.
WHEN I STARTED TO TALK TO HER
ABOUT MY OWN EXPERIENCES AL
AMERIGO?
SHE TOLD ME ABOUT THE TIME WHEN
SHE WAS CLEANING OUTSIDE OF THE
MOTEL ROOM.
AND ANNA MOTEL GUYS FROM --
PROPOSITIONED HER FROM HIS CAR
[INAUDIBLE]
COMPLETELY NAKED.
AS AN IMMIGRANT WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH AND AVAILABLE RESOURCES
SHE WAS UNABLE TO SEEK RECOURSE.
I ALSO WITNESS THEM IMPACTS OF
DISPARAGEMENT WHEN MY CO WORKER
CAME FORWARD WITH HER STORY.
MY GOOD FRIEND AND CO WORKER
HANNAH.
WHO IS ALSO A SERVER?
TELL ME THAT SHE HAD A BIRD SHE
HAD REPORTED BEINGS ASSAULTED BY
THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE HOTEL
[INAUDIBLE]
I HEARD.
FROM THE CO WORKERS THAT AFTER
HANNAH MADE HER COMPLAINT.
THEY HAD BEEN CALLED INTO A
MEETING I WISH MANAGEMENT
UNDERMINE.
HIM AS A CRUTCH CREDIBILITY.
AND THE OTHER WORKERS IN THE
RESTAURANT THAT SHE WAS ONCE
CLOSE TO THE BECAME.
THE BEGAN TURNING THEIR BACKS
AGAINST HER.
ALONG WITH ME BECAUSE THOSE WHO
SEE IT WITH THEIR EVEN AFTER SHE
LEFT MORE TORN AND TEAMS
CONTINUE TO MAKE JOKES.
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND IT MIMI FEEL LIKE THERE ARE
NO REPERCUSSIONS FOR THIS KIND.
AS LONG AS BE AS LONG AS WE'RE
TOLD THAT OUR STORIES DO NOT
MATTER WHEN YOU PICK UP ABOUT
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THIS THIS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
THE CULTURE IN THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY.
UNFORTUNATELY ME AND ARE NOT THE
ONLY WOMEN.
VIA SUSPECTS BROUGHT IT IS TO
EXPERIENCE THIS KIND OF RETREAT
OVER THAT THIS KIND OF TREATMENT.
AT THE RIVER PALMS RESORT AND
ABOUT THEM.
WOMEN CAME FORWARD WITH
ALLEGATIONS OF HARASSMENT.
AND RETALIATION.
AND THE CASE RESULTED AND A TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
SETTLEMENT.
I FEEL THAT THE ONLY WAY TO
TACKLE THIS ISSUE IS DO
COMPREHENSIVE LEGISLATION THAT
WILL KEEP WOMEN SAVE FROM
ASSAULT.
HARASSMENT AND RETALIATION.
WHEN THEY COME FORWARD --
SO MEMBER OF THE ROCKIES SOMEONE
IS IN THE STATUS THOUGHT THIS --
BECAUSE FIT AND IT'S THEM I MEAN
THERE'S NO SAFETY WHEN --
EVEN THOUGH THAT SIMPLE STATE
IT'LL.
LOOK OUTSIDE THE S. WASHER.
OR LOAN US THAT THAT --
HIGH GETTING NEEDS HI GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS --
CARLO AND I'M A MEMBER WITH NO.
AND I WORK IN THE INDUSTRY OF
RESTAURANTS --
BECAUSE OF WHERE IT CAME.
SO HOW THEN SHARED THE NEWS
WATCHER.
COOL MICHAEL PUT IT ON TOP OF
YEAR KNUCKLE SONG WHICH'LL.
MAN MAY.
NOT CAUSE US.
EATING THAT THEY MEET THE CAUSAL
EVEN AS YOUNG WOMAN.
I AM AND SO I AM I WOULD WORK
AND I OF THOSE I WOULD WORK WITH
THIS -- MEN.
AND I WORKED AS A DISHWASHER AND
SO THIS --
THIS GENTLEMEN OR SORRY MAN --
THIS MEN --
WOULD INSINUATE THAT YOU WOULD
WANT TO TOUCH ME THAT HE WOULD --
ONE GOAL PAST --
GOAL PAST THOSE LIMITS.
EEO DON'T KNOW THE GOOD ONE
FOLLOWED.
THE MOMENT WAS TO COMMIT FOCUS
[INAUDIBLE]
THE AND COMMERCE OR WAYS --
OVER YET [INAUDIBLE]
METASIA.
I GO MORE GHOST STORY THIS
EPISODE WE WILL STOP AND IT EFM
LITTLE YOU'LL SAVE HER BUT OF
COURSE LAWS [INAUDIBLE]
THEY LIVE.
MORE JUST BECAUSE IBM DOES THAT
DO TO YOU ALL RIGHT FOR THE FOR
YOU KNOW WHICH OF THOSE
THROUGHOUT THE IN THIS THE UP.
BUTTON ABOUT ABUNDANCE JUST
BELOW.
THE LOWER.
ALMOST OUT MADE TO PUT ACROSS A
LOT.
ALMOST A PERSON OF THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE OF WITNESSING.
AND SO --
AND SO HE ARM WOULD TOUCH ME AND
HE WOULDN'T LISTEN MULTIPLE
TIMES HE WOULD JUST KEEP --
TRYING TO TOUCH ME AND I WOULD
TELL HIM NO AND SO I AM A PRAYER
ON THE TYPE OF ANYTHING THAT
NEEDED TO BE HELPED ON BUT I
SIZE KEPT --
TELLING HIM TO NOT TOUCH ME TO
NOT UP TO STOP HARASSING ME HE
WOULD A I'D START INSULTING ME
HE WOULD SAY YOU BELONG IN
WASHING IN THE RESTROOMS YOU
BELONG AT HOME TAKING CARE OF
YOUR KIDS --
YOU DON'T BELONG HERE SO HE
WOULD JUST KEEP INSULTING ME IN
THAT TYPE OF MATTER --
AS LONG AS I KEPT ON TELLING HIM
TO STOP HARASSING ME.
SO JOIN LIVE HERE ON THE MONEY.
WELL YOU TO SAY AFTER YET I
SMOKE YEAH IT.
IAN THONG SAYS MEDICAL TO GET IF
DEVELOPMENTS YOU.
YOU KNOW YOUR HOME ON THE FUEL
SO KNOW THE A GOVERNMENT AUDIO.
OLD RELIGIOUS THE CANDLE.
AND SO -- MY
NEXT STEP WAS TO SPEAK TO THE
MANAGER I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT I SPOKE.
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE
MANAGER WAS HIS EX GIRLFRIENDS
IF SO WHAT THE MANAGER SAID TO
ME WAS --
WHAT YOU WANT WANT ME TO CALL
THE COPS AND SO --
I JUST I TOLD THEIR I DON'T WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN.
AND SO [INAUDIBLE]
THE GOVERNMENT.
AND ALL I ASKED FOR WAS THAT I
DIDN'T WANT ANY COSTS AND LOSS
THAT I JUST WANTED HER TO TEACH
MY SCHEDULE MY WORKING SCHEDULE.
HERE AT THE SCHOOL AND SET UP
ALSO THE END YOU EIGHT YEAH
GONNA YOU. ONE IS THAT A RADICAL
BUT IF YOU'LL SOME ACCORDION
WORKED ON AND SO THEN THAT'S
WHEN US OLD STARTED NOT ONLY
FROM HIM BUT ALSO FROM HER.
SO ACCURATE LEAVE THE WORK
PLEASE FILL US ALL NOT ONLY CAME
FROM THE MEN BUT ALSO FROM THE
ONE FROM THAT HIS EX GIRLFRIEND
WHO WANTED TO JUST LEAD ME TO
JUST QUIT MY JOB.
HE ENDED UP EAST OF WHERE
MOTIVATED BY A VERY POWERFUL SET
UP QUITE A LOCAL MUSICAL BUT YOU
KNOW IN THE MOVIE THE OWNER KNEW.
IAGO STEALS A MEMORABLE SORENESS
IN A AND SO I AM WHAT I CAN.
I ENDED UP DOING WAS TRYING TO
SWITCH THE SCHEDULE WITH --
MY OTHER COWORKER BUT SHE ENDED
UP TO THE SWITCH ME BACK TO THE
OTHERS.
WITH MY OTHER ARM COWORKER.
COMEY IT WHAT THE OFFICE OF THE
REQUEST OF THE US GIMMICK IT IS
SORT OF THE HUMBLENESS SCHEMATIC.
ENJOY CHANGE THE SCHEDULE FOUR
TIMES AND I ENDED UP ONLY
WORKING OUT OF THOSE FOUR TIMES
ONLY TO DAIS MONDAY AND TUESDAY.
WHAT CARE ENOUGH LIKE HOW WHICH
WILL LEAD US TO BE A GOOD
ECONOMIC POLICY FLORAL AROMATIC?
BOB GORDON MOST EMBLEMS METRIC
TONS.
AND SO I ENDED UP ONLY WORKING
THOSE TWO DAYS BECAUSE THROUGH
ALL OF THIS WHO WAS SUCH A
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE EVERY TIME
I WOULD SEE HIM.
IT WAS JUST THIS FEELING OF
FEELING DISCUSS THEIR JUST THIS
FEELING OF NOT WANTING TO BE
THERE.
YOU THIS IS THE END POSES OF
THEM ARE GOING ON AND LEFT.
AND SO I DECIDED TO ON TAKE IT A
STEP FURTHER AFTER SPEAKING TO
THE MANAGER AND SPEAK AND SPEAK
TO THE ACTUAL OWNER OF THE
RESTAURANT.
HE'D BETTER THE SYSTEM OUT THERE
YEAH GOAL IS TO WE ARE YOU KNOW
LOOKING LOW ON MONEY.
AND SO I TOLD THE OWNER SLOW
THAT I WANTED A DIFFERENT
MANAGER THAT I DON'T WANT HIS EX
GIRLFRIEND TO BE PRESENT AS I
SPOKE TO ON TO HIM.
NEED LOW OF MEDICAL GOOD
KENNAWAY ETCETERA BUT GIVEN THE
POLITICAL DIALOGUE IN.
AND SO -- HE
PRESENTED HE PROCEEDED TO TELL
ME THAT I COULD DO ANYTHING.
THAT IT WAS HIS WORD AGAINST
MINE.
WHAT CAN I --
INSTALL ON HE PROCEEDED TO TELL
ME THAT I TOLD HIM MY GOING TO
FIRE HIM AND ALL HE TOLD ME WAS
I CAN'T DO THAT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
GRUMBLE GRUMBLE YOUR CLAMOR
MILLION SIX MILLION INNOCENT
THAT'LL COME IN SOUTHERN IRAQ
[INAUDIBLE]
AND AND I ALSO MUST WHAT THE
GOOD IDEA THE BILL SORT OF MONEY
AS A MOUSE.
THE FEES HUMIDITY PARA MADE THEM
FARM LAND IN NEW YALLA.
I THINK EAGER ROCK HE'LL MAKONI
MEAN FOR OF MY OWN THE MEANS
THAT AGENCY ME THEY WOULD'VE PUT
DIPLOMA CLOSER TO ONE ANOTHER.
USUALLY DOESN'T PUTS ON A CASE
NOT BOTTLE.
OKAY SEAGOING SINGAPORE'S
MEDICARE.
NOT PUT COMMANDED US GOING TO
PREVENT THAT WOULD GIVE US SOME
BUT ON THE BORDER WITH IRAQ.
HE THE DON'T LOOK YOUR BUT OF A
RECOVERABLE LOOK AT IT BUT WE
PROBABLY COULD DO IT JUST FOR
THE RECORD IN THE PUT CHEMICALS
ON I'M A SEATTLE BUT I MEAN
THOSE ON THE I'M AND SO --
AND SO THEY KEPT SWITCHING THE
MANAGERS IN THE MOUNTAINS.
I JUST WANT --
SANDRA IF YOU CAN CLARIFY
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THAT HOTELS SOMETIMES
THAT THERE IS A STAFFING AGENCY.
WAS YOUR HARASSER PART OF THE
STAFFING AGENCY ARE PART OF THAT
DIRECT HOTEL STAFF.
WAREHOUSE HOW DOES THAT WORK
THEY BRING IN WORKERS THE
STAFFING AGENCY TO WORK.
AT THE HOTEL IN THE HOTEL SAYS
YOU'RE NOT OUR WORKERS
.
UP SO NO HAN CSK CONDUCT AN
UPPER SO NICE GET SOMETHING
GOING ON US AND NOW I PERSONAS
GETS ALMOST ME SUSS OUT MENTAL
PROCESS IS IT --
THAN THAT NOTHING THAT LOOKED
MENTAL --
THAT'S ON US GARY SANK IN THIS
ISSUE NOW MOST IMPROBABLE MOTHER
SO BAD* --
GLOBAL PERSONAS.
BEEN MIDDLESEX.
A OR SEVEN AS THEY LOOK
INCLUSIVE IT LOOKS NEW MOST
OFTEN NOTICE THAT LOOK BETTER
SAW THAT KNOWS THEY KNOW THAT
THE JOB PEOPLE LIKE SINGLE
MOTHERS PEOPLE THAT THE THEY
THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED THAT THEY
KNOW THAT WON'T SPEAK UP BECAUSE
OF BEING AFRAID BUT ALSO BECAUSE
THEY DON'T.
WANT TO GET THE POLICE INVOLVED
SO THEY JUST HIRED THE MOST
VULNERABLE EVEN THE OTHER
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE PERMANENT
WORKERS AT THE HOTEL.
TREAT THEM AS THEY WERE
INVISIBLE LAST OF THEIR NOTHING
AND THEY DON'T TAKE THE MASS TO
USE THAT THE SHIP.
I GOT TO GET OUT --
GOOGLE BUT DON'T FORGET THIS --
UP TO WHAT THE GOVERNMENT DID
NOT SO CLOSE THAT I HAD SOME OF
THEM NOT SO MOST NOT I'M NOT IN
THE MOST THE MOST NEW US TALK.
YEAH LOOK AT HIM BUT UPON INKING.
QUE ESCUCHA MISS COMPANION
ASSIST TO BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
ALLOW THIS.
YES THE ESKIMOS COMES.
Y. LOUDER WELL DONE NOTHING.
SO IF.
YEAH BUT IT ALSO BROUGHT IN ALL
BUT IN THE SUMMER BUT I'M NOT
BUT ANOTHER.
THING TO SEE THAT HE'S COMBINED
YES BECAUSE THE WHOLE THING IN
THE FIFTEEN SHE SAID THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT EVEN THOUGH
SHE WON HER LOST.
TO THIS SOMETHING THAT'S STILL
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN TO THE HOUSE --
FRIENDS THAT WORK IN THAT HOTEL
IN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE THERE HAS ALREADY BEEN.
LAWSUIT AND ALL THAT EXISTS AT
THE CONTINUOUS --
PROBLEM. ONE OUT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
SOME OF THE SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO USE
SUCCESSFULLY ABLE TO DO ONE OF
THOSE THINGS YOU MENTIONED WAS
THE PANIC BUTTON.
I KNOW WE HAD LEGISLATION THAT
WAS TRYING TO GET PANIC BUTTONS
AND ALL THE HOTELS BUT THERE WAS
A QUESTION REGARDING HOW MUCH IT
WOULD COST.
AND THAT WAS THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
THE ARGUMENT WAS THAT IT DIDN'T
MATTER HOW MUCH IT COST IT IT
WAS A SAFE GUARD TO PROTECT THE
WORKERS CAN YOU TELL US WHY A
PANIC BUTTON.
IS SO IMPORTANT FOR YOU.
AQUA SIDE HURT IS SOME READY I
WORKING IN SOME AWFUL TELLS
THING IN NEW YORK AND CHICAGO.
AND IT IS THEY TALK ABOUT REALLY
GOOD BEING SOMEBODY AND IN LUCKY
ONE MATTER THAT --
LABEL A THE DANGER NGUYEN.
IF WE ACTIVATE THAT THAT THE PUN
ABOUT THEM IN.
I MEAN HELP WILL COME IN MEDIUM.
SAW -- I
WILL TELL AGREED. TO FOR THE
PANIC BUTTON AND OUR FIRST
CONTRACT SO THAT'S THAT'S BRING
YOU SEE THEY HAVE WE EVEN BEFORE
WE PASS IT ALONG.
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU.
I ALSO WANTED TO ASK THE NINE IT
APPEARS [INAUDIBLE]
THAT WHAT WE'RE TALKING.
ACTUAL HARASSMENT IT ISN'T SOME
IT JUST HAPPENS ONCE AND YOU
NEVER HEAR ABOUT IT.
IN YOUR CASE IT'S GENERATIONAL
HOW DID YOUR MOTHER FEEL WHEN
YOU SHARED WITH HER THAT YOU ARE
ALSO EXPERIENCING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THE SAME THING AS SHE WOULD HAVE
EXPERIENCED AS A YOUNG WOMAN.
WELL MY GRANDMOTHER NEVER TOLD
ME ABOUT.
PLAGUE HER EXPERIENCE.
UNTIL I HAD VOICED MY OPINION
ARE [INAUDIBLE]
EXPERIENCE.
SHE KNEW THAT I WAS GOING TO BE
WORKING THERE.
AND IT WAS A GRAND. FOR HER TO
SEAL A HOW MUCH HARD WORK.
WHEN SHE WAS THE HOUSEKEEPER?
WHAT TO REALLY COUNT EXPECTANTLY?
USE THAT AS A WAY FOR ME TO WORK
HARD.
AND YOU KNOW KNOW THAT OKAY THAT
YOU HAVE TO WORK HARD THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU WANT
[INAUDIBLE] TO KEEP DOING YOU
MIGHT BE ABLE TO STRIVE HARDER
THERE WHERE SHE HAD CAME FROM
BECAUSE YOU KNOW --
MY GRANDMOTHER WHEN I HAD TOLD
HER ABOUT THAT SHE YOU KNOW.
THAT'S WHEN SHE STARTED TELLING
ME OF ALL OF THOSE THINGS AND I
HAD NO IDEA.
THAT.
SHE HAD EXPERIENCE THAT.
AND SO LAKE WHEN THAT HAPPENED I
WAS.
I WAS MAYBE IT MAYBE LIKE
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
THAT.
THE INCIDENT HAD OCCURRED AND SO
WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT NOW ONLY
IF I WAS THAT SHE WOULD HAVE
TOLD ME THAT WHILE SHE WAS STILL
WORKING THERE.
I WOULD HAVE TOLD REALLY YOU
KNOW TOLD ALL THE RESOURCES AGO
TO HOW TO DO IT YOU KNOW.
I WOULD HAVE TRIED TO HELP AS
MUCH AS THEY COULD BUT BECAUSE
HE NEVER TOLD ME.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH MY AGE AT
THE TIME YOU KNOW IT KIND OF
HURTS BAD LIKE. TO KNOW THAT AT
LEAST LAKE WHERE WE CAN FINALLY
MAKE A DIFFERENCE RALLIES.
YOU KNOW FOR HER STORY TO BE
TOLD.
YOU KNOW IF IT MAKES.
IT MEANS A LOT I AM WHEN I HAD
TOLD HER ABOUT THOSE BABY IN
THIS EVENT.
SHE WAS VERY EXCITED AND YOU
KNOW AYE AYE SIR ABOUT YOU KNOW
MORE DETAILS ABOUT.
TUITION AND SEE.
SHE FELT REALLY HAPPY TO FINALLY
VOICE HER OPINION. FOR FOR HER
TO FEEL THAT HER VOICE IS.
HER FOR ONCE [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
AND THEN ONE LAST QUESTION. TO
ANOTHER.
ONE THAT'S JUST WHAT WE NEED
THEY WHAT THE MY LAI.
USS PORTLAND OKAY CHUCKY IN
MISTER BY THE SENATE YOU THAT
ABOVE ALL COST ABOUT HOW THE
LOTUS.
OR TO GET GOING TO LAS BIG GUY
DON'T ONCE YOU THINK THAT'LL IN
REALLY THAT IS ON THE COURT GET
WET AND THEN IT.
WOULD GET THE SYSTEM IN A LOT
FOR YOUR THEM WE JUST TOUCHED ON
US NOR SILENTLY LEVELS IS LEVELS
THAN WE JUST THIS ON US.
IT IT GOOD MOVIE THAT LET LET ME
LET ME SEE THE I HAVE A QUESTION
IT COULD BE FOR ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER OR EVEN.
SOME OF THE PANEL WHICH IS AS WE
SEEN OVER THE LAST A YEAR OR
MORE.
WITH THE DISCUSSIONS AND THE
MEDIA -- THE
DISCUSSIONS AMONGST EACH AND
EVEN IN YOUR WORKPLACE AND WITH
LEGISLATION MOVING HAVE YOU SEEN
ANY CHANGES [INAUDIBLE]
BEEF -- IT
LIEU OF LEGISLATION SO WERE
MOVING LEGISLATION BUT IT HASN'T
BEEN A COMPLETELY SIGNED IN ITS
NOT IN ACTED THAT ARE YOU
ALREADY SEEN CHANGES JUST
BECAUSE OF THE DISCUSSION.
OR NOT REALLY.
SEE AND YOU KNOW BUT SOME NOT
FOR LONG.
THE COLOMBIAN DRUG THE PRODUCT
IS THE APPLE IN MOST THAT WENT
IN AND YOU DON'T KNOW THAT IN
LOS AYE WITHOUT UP IDEAS
COMBINED YES.
I DON'T FADED SITTING STILL EAT
AIM MUST TAKE IF I'M HOMELESS.
WOULD THAT MONEY FEES.
THEY HAVE ALLOWED.
IT IS THAT YOU KNOW I WAS.
FATAL IMMORTAL ADULT.
ASK THAT WE BE OUT WEST BANK
STATEMENT OUT MEANS THAT HIS
YEAH WITHOUT.
OUT BUT I DON'T I YOU KNOW I
THINK I'VE HAD MOST OF IT WILL
MORE THE VENDETTA MOVES.
SO -- YET
STILL FOR US --
IN OUR LOCAL --
ESSAY YOU'RE W. W. AS PASSING
THE BILL IT WAS IT WAS A VERY --
WE WERE ABLE TO SEE --
SORRY TREE WE STARTED --
LETTING WOMEN AND NOT ONLY WOMEN
BUT MEN ALSO KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
RIGHTS THAT THERE'S THAT WE GOAL
AND TELL THEM LIKE LOOK THIS IS
WHAT YOU CAN DO.
AND SO WE'VE WE'VE ALL DONE THAT
THROUGH OUR LEGISLATION AND A
HALF TO HELP THOSE OPENED LACKEY --
IN MY CASE --
ECONOMIST PAUL FATTA THAT UNIONS
YOU KNOW NICE THE WHOLE TONE.
DOES THAT THE FRIEND I WITHIN
THEM.
I GUESS THE MORE --
AWARENESS --
FOR IF IF IF THERE IS THEN THE
US RIGHT THERE WALKING IN THE
HALLWAY.
THERE ARE MORE AWARE BECAUSE WAS
LIMON WE HAVE A VOICE NOW.
SO THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE NOW --
ANY GUY SO AND GO MINE THAT AN
ATHENS OKAY.
BUT I MEAN NOT ONLY WILL COME
YOU -- AND
UP THE SIDE OF THE GATE.
LET'S GET OUT OF THAT NOW NOW
NEON NO THAT'S ON US.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT I'M THAT
IS GAY?
IT'S THE NOT A COMP BOOK AND
THEY DON'T LET ME IS MY COMPANY
AND THOSE I SUBMIT THAT WE
HANDLE.
IT IS THAT THEY MORE.
CM BUT ABOUT THAT A JUSTIN AND
WOOD SHOP THAT.
WHAT IS THE HOT WAS GOING TO
COME BY THE US LOOK AT BASRA
LISTEN THAT THAT THAT THE ME AT
THE HOTTEST OF HOT BODIES?
GETS NOT FUSSY GETS THE KITE
GAVEL HE SAY IT OUT OF SOMETHING
THAT THEY ALSO ALL BUT THERE'S A
POWERFUL ALSO IN THE COOPER SO
NICE LIMON LOW NOTICED WHEN I DO
THAT.
IT'S NOT MEANT DAY WHAT YOU SEEM.
HI SALLY THAT CAN ASSIST WHICH
CAN GET NOW NOT THAT IT WAS
PICKED UP BY HEALTH BOTH BY
SACRAMENTO CA I KNOW.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T THINK I'M.
A YES I THINK THEY HAVE MOST
LIKELY BY --
DOT AWAY AND STILL IT THERE OFF
THERE HASN'T BEEN THAT --
DRASTIC TEENS MANY MEMBERS ARE
TOO SCARED BUT THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S UNIONS THAT HAVE
HELPED THEM.
LIKE IN MY CASE MY UNION WAS
ABLE TO HELP ME --
BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE STILL NEEDS
TO BE A LOT OF MORE WORK DONE
THIS KIND OF LIKE --
THERE'S LIKE THIS MAYOR THAT THE
COMPANIES TRY TO MAKE IT SEEM
LIKE THERE HAS BEEN CHANGE BUT
IN REALITY NOTHING HAS CHANGED
FOR US.
AND HE GOT SO --
ONE OF THE BUDGET OF THE MUSICAL.
IN A PROPOSAL FOR A GIFT
THURMOND LONG THAT I DON'T LIKE
THAT IDEA.
EITHER WAY UP THE MUSICAL PUT
CAN LIVE ON SCHOOL DID SO. FOR A
LOT OF GREAT MOMENTS OF
CONSUMING THOSE --
SUBJECTIVE LIVE.
FIVE ALMOST IDENTICAL SALINAS
THROUGH THE SUN HAS A BASKETBALL.
MODEL A LOCAL MEDICAL MONTH WE
DON'T KNOW I'M FICKLE DEMON --
SO IN MY CASE --
I ALSO HAD A GOOD POINT YEAH WHO
SHE ALSO PUT A COMPLETE IN THERE
WHERE PAID HER THEY WERE GIVING
HER BREAKS.
NONE OF HER FIFTEEN MINUTE
BREAKS AND THEY I'M NOT GONNA
PAY JUST --
KEEP BY SAVING GIVEN THEM THIS
CONTRACT THE WORKERS WOULD LOSE
MANY OF THEIR RIGHTS AT THE
WORKPLACE.
SOUL ONS JUST LIKE --
JUST LIKE THE FOOTBALL HERO
FOUND OUT THERE HASN'T BEEN AS
MUCH CHANGES THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO SEE.
I I HAVE REAL BASIC QUESTION.
DO YOU FEEL SAFE.
IT BOTHERS ME BECAUSE I I CAN
HEAR YOUR VOICE AND THAT YOU'RE
STILL SCARED.
AND THAT --
I WISH THAT THERE WAS.
MAYBE WITHIN THE MEANS THAT DID.
SOME COUNSELING WITH YOU BECAUSE
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET OVER
THAT --
BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING WORSE
AYE.
I HAD -- WAS
HARASSED YEARS AND YEARS AGO AND
WHAT THE TECHNOLOGY FIELD.
AND IT'S VERY SIMILAR.
THAT YOU NEVER GET ENOUGH CAN
HAVE A JOB.
BUT I I WANT TO ASSURE YOU THAT
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN
BE SAFE.
AND THAT'S MY MY ROLE HERE I
THINK IS LEGISLATORS TO MAKE
SURE.
WELL AND I THINK --
ON A COULD TELL YOU ONE OF THE
GREAT THINGS ABOUT A STARTING
WITH -- THE
JANITORS BILL BEFORE ALL OF THIS
CAME OUT IS THAT WE GOT THAT
BILL PASSED WITH SOME BASIC
PROTECTIONS THAT WE NEEDED.
BUT NOW WE'RE ON AROUND TOO
BECAUSE THE UNION DID COME
TOGETHER AFTER THAT BILL --
WITH THE FORCE COOPERATION OF
THE COMPANIES --
TO TRY TO START A PROCESS OF
EMPOWERING THE WORKERS AND NOW
THEY'RE BACK WITH THE MOST
INNOVATIVE PROGRAM THAT WE'VE
EVER SEEN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
CAN THE BILL AND TO AND TO HAVE.
IT AND I'VE BEEN TO TO LEARN HOW
TO PROTECT THEMSELVES BOTH
PHYSICALLY AND LEGALLY AND
THROUGH THEIR UNION AND I THINK
IT'S GONNA I HOPE IT'S GOING TO
BE A MODEL FOR OTHER WORKPLACES
SO IT.
AND YEAH --
AND JUST QUICKLY AS WELL I THINK
I'VE BEEN ALONGSIDE WITH MY MOM
INTO THIS BY --
DO ALL OF THIS SO IT'S BEEN VERY
LIFE TEACHING AND ALSO THE LOCAL
IS WORKING ON ALSO STARTING --
A SMALL PROMOTE VOTER GROUPS
WITH YOUTH I ALSO WORK WITH OUR
VIEWS AS WELL SO IT'S BEEN A
GREAT JOURNEY --
WORKING ON WITH --
MRS FLETCHER AND ALONG WITH MANY
WOMEN LIKE MY MOM. TO PASS THIS
BILL CONTINUE WORKING IN
BUILDING THAT COUNSELING FOR
WOMEN AND NOT ONLY FOR WOMEN BUT
MEN WE HAVE A GROUP OF
GRANDFATHER'S WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP ON ALSO BUILDING NOT ONLY
FOR WOMEN BECAUSE NOT ONLY DOES
IT ONLY HAPPEN TO WOMEN.
BUT ALSO MEN AND BUILDING THAT
AS ALSO THAT FUTURE GENERATIONS
THAT THROUGH --
OF THE UNIONS TO COME TO ALSO
HAVE THAT COUNTS VIENEN HELL TO
BE ABLE TO HELP OTHER YOUTH WITH
IN THE UNION AND BUILT THAT --
FOUND THEY SET UP AN EARLY ON
PROGRAM AS WELL.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE.
WE'RE GOING. TO FOR ALL WORKERS
[INAUDIBLE]
HOPEFULLY OUR ACTUAL WORKERS
WILL.
THE GROUND IF THEY CAN'T.
THIS PART [INAUDIBLE]
TO THE MOMENT
.
HEY EVERYONE WHO PARKED IN THE
OVERFLOW LOT --
ACROSS THE STREET YOU CAN PICK
UP A PARKING VALIDATION AT THE
AND IN THE FAR CORNER OVER THERE
.
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE NEXT A
PANELIST [INAUDIBLE]
PLEASE COME.
I'VE TO THE TABLE WE WANT
ENCOURAGE THE NEXT SET A
PANELIST
[INAUDIBLE]
MOST OF
YEAH.
AND WHILE THE PITCHERS ARE BEING
TAKEN WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
NEXT SET A PANELIST.
PLEASE MAKE YOUR WEIGHT.
I TO YOUR SEAT.
AND WILL BE GETTING STARTED VERY
SHORTLY [INAUDIBLE]
I'M LISTENING.
AND WE WANT TO GET THE NEXT SET
OF PANELISTS.
AND IF EVERYBODY [INAUDIBLE]
WHO'S PARTICIPATING [INAUDIBLE]
CAN SIT.
CAN GO AHEAD AND SIT DOWN SO WE
CAN BEGIN.
WE WOULD GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU.
AND WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED NOW THAT THE CHAIRS BACK
SO.
WE ONE LITTLE
.
SO LET'S GO GET IN HERE AND
HEADING GET STARTED ON THE GO
AHEAD AND HAND IT ONCE MORE
[INAUDIBLE]
CHAIR.
I THINK YOU KNOW.
AND I'M EXCITED NOW WE'RE GONNA
HEAR -- SOME
STRATEGIES TO HOPEFULLY TAKE
THIS THIS ISSUE HEAD ON I WILL
AND I WILL NOTE THAT AS SOMEBODY
WHO CAME FROM THE LABOR MOVEMENT.
I THINK THERE ARE THOSE OF US
PROBABLY A LOT OF US HERE WHO
KNOW THAT THE BEST WAY TO
PROTECT WORKERS IS --
THROUGH THE POWER OF A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND AND LETTING THEM HAVE A
VOICE ON THE JOB AS WE'VE HEARD
SO ELOQUENTLY FROM WANNA.
ABOUT HER UNION --
ABERDEEN FIRST CONTRACT FOR A
PANIC BUTTON THAT'S PRETTY MAY
SEEM I HAVE.
NOT ALL WORKERS UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE UNIONS AND EVEN WITH UNIONS
WE STILL NEED. FOR OUR WORKERS
TO ESTABLISH A FRAMEWORK
SOMETIMES TO FORCE COMPANIES TO
ACTUALLY PAY ATTENTION SO I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL HEAR SOME
EXCITING SAY I THINK WHERE IS
EVERYBODY LENT IF YOU'RE.
GOOD WAS STARTING READY --
THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN.
AND ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING HERE MY NAME IS MIGHTY
LITTLE GOOD ASTLE AND I'M VICE
PRESIDENT OF UNITE HERE
INTERNATIONAL UNION.
AND THE ASIDE FROM HAVING SO
MANY WOMEN HERE.
NEXT TO COURAGEOUS MEN I'M
ESPECIALLY PROUD TO HAVE HEARD
FROM THE WOMEN ON THE PANEL.
PREVIOUS PREVIOUSLY BECAUSE IT
TOOK A LOT OF COURAGE TO COME
OUT AND THE PUBLIC IN WITH THEIR
STORIES.
SO I THINK FOR ALL OF US THE
ISSUE IS ABOUT --
POWER IN THE WORKPLACE.
AND THE WORST THE IMBALANCE IS A
POWER THE WORSE THE ABUSES.
YOU CAN TAKE ALL THESE LAYERS
FIRST THERE'S THE LAYER OF WOMEN.
AND THERE'S A LAYER OF WOMEN OF
COLOR.
THEN THERE'S THAT LAYER OF
IMMIGRANT WOMEN [INAUDIBLE]
UNDOCUMENTED WOMEN.
AND WOMEN WITHOUT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS THOSE ARE ALL
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF IMBALANCE IN
THE WORKPLACE.
AND IT'S ESPECIALLY BAD IN THIS
INDUSTRY AS YOU HEARD --
LIKE HOSPITALITY.
SO --
MENTIONED BY SOUND THOUGH WAS
THAT TERRY NAY A RESORT AND I
JUST.
I'M JILL BY LAS VEGAS WHO WOULD
THINK.
THAT IN SUCH A BEAUTIFUL
BEAUTIFUL RESORT AREA THESE
KINDS OF A OF THINGS WOULD BE
TAKING PLACE.
BUT THEY RELY ON SUBCONTRACTED
OUT WORKERS LIKE SOUND THAT.
THEY HAVE A RESORT WHERE
HOUSEKEEPERS HAVE TO ENTER THE
ROOM -- ROOM
AFTER ROOM ALONE --
THEY FEEL THE WHOLE RESORT FILLS
IN ADDITION TO SUBCONTRACTED OUT
OF THE OF THE REGULAR EMPLOYEES.
SUBCONTRACTED OUT EMPLOYEES AND
ANOTHER.
STATUS WHICH IS J. ONE VISAS
[INAUDIBLE]
OKAY.
SO THESE ARE ALL THE DIFFERENT
WAYS IN WHICH THIS EMPLOYER IS
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF EMPLOYEES.
AND THEY ALL HAVE A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF RIGHTS ON THE JOB LESS
AND LESS AND LESS --
SO I JUST WANT TO SUM UP --
THE POLICIES THAT WE THINK OF
WOULD.
HELP THESE WOMEN AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGAK CURRY SAID HOW TO
MAKE THEM SAFE ONE IS THE
CURRENT LEGISLATION SPONSORED BY.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ FLETCHER
AB THREO EIGHT ONE TO MAKE
COMPANIES LIABLE FOR THE
SUBCONTRACT SUBCONTRACTED OUT
WORKERS --
JOINT LIABILITY IT EXISTS FOR
WAGE THAT BUT A IT SHOULD ALSO
APPLY TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SECOND PANIC BUTTONS --
AS YOU ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT
PANIC BUTTONS IT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE --
AND WE ARE.
LAW SUPPORTING OUR UNION IS
SUPPORTING.
A DIFFERENT WAYS OF ARE
REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE.
WORKERS WITH PANIC BUTTONS AND
OTHER PROTECTION SO THAT THEY
COULD SPEAK OUT [INAUDIBLE]
SEOUL.
ON LONG BEACH THERE IS A AND
INITIATIVE THAT'S PENDING TO BE
PUT ON THE BALLOT.
I'M JUST BY WILL BEAR THIS
THERE'S AN INITIATIVE THAT'S
PENDING TO BE PUT ON THE BALLOT.
OTHER STATE LEGISLATION A. B.
SET.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN MORE SEARCHING.
THERE IS THE IN OAKLAND THERE IS
ON INITIATIVE ON PANIC BUTTONS
THAT'S PENDING --
AS YOU ALL KNOW IN --
THE FIRST ONE THAT WAS PASSED
YEAH OUT OF WASHINGTON.
THAT WAS PASSED UP AN INITIATIVE --
AT LARGE AND IT WAS HIGHLY
SUPPORTED BY THE VOTERS.
AND THEN AGAIN --
THE CHICAGO CITY ALSO PASSED --
A LAW ON THE CITY COUNCIL SO
THEY HAVE IT IN PLACE --
SO THOSE ARE EXAMPLES OF THE
VARIOUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION --
THAT --
SUPPORT THE RIGHT POLICIES THIRD
WE NEED IMMIGRATION REFORM
[INAUDIBLE]
WE NEED.
UNFORTUNATELY IF THE WORLD TO
THIS PANEL THINK WE WOULD HAVE
PASSED IT BY NOW.
IF IT WAS UP TO THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE WE WHAT A PASSED
IMMIGRATION REFORM BY NOW.
I KNOW IT'S NOT IN.
OUR HANDS SPECIFICALLY BUT WE
HAVE TO KEEP FIGHTING FOR IT
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY TO CREATE
MORE EQUALITY ON IN THE
WORKPLACE AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE.
THAT THERE ARE --
THAT NO GUEST WORKER PROGRAMS
EXIST ALT WITHOUT FULL AND EQUAL
RIGHTS OF U. S. WORKERS WITHOUT
PEOPLE RIGHTS THEN THEY WILL BE
TAKEN OF ADVANTAGE OF AND THE
LAST POLICY THAT I WOULD LIKE.
TO RECOMMEND AND THAT IS
UNIONIZATION.
UNIONIZATION AND SHOULD NOT BE
SOMETHING WITH THE WORKERS FIGHT
AFTER THREE OR FOUR YEARS AND
THEY FINALLY WIN.
UNIONIZATION SHOULD BE A POLICY
PERIOD THAT IS IMPLEMENTED EVERY
SINGLE WAY AND THAT THE LAW OF
THE LAND ACTUALLY GET
IMPLEMENTED AND NOT JUST --
MADE FUN OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK YOU CHAIR GONZALEZ
FLETCHER OFFER THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN TO THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KATHY SPELLER I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY FOUNDATION.
AND THE EXECUTIVE EDITOR OF MS
MAGAZINE WHICH WE PUBLISH --
THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE I
BROUGHT COPIES OF OUR SUMMER
ISSUE WE HAVE A FEATURE --
SUMMARIZING SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM A RECENT
NATIONAL CONFERENCE --
MARIA ELENA WAS THERE AND
PARTICIPATED ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER --
CIVIL RIGHTS --
AND WOMEN THIS --
TO OUTLINED SOME OF THE FEDERAL
LEGAL --
ISSUES AND SOME OF THE CHANGES
TO FEDERAL LAWS --
THAT WERE SORELY NEEDED AS WELL
AS OTHER STRATEGIES --
I ALSO BROUGHT WITH ME AND I
WILL LEAVE FOR THE COMMITTEE --
HAVE VERY RECENT ARTICLE IN THE
STANFORD LAW REVIEW WAS --
COMPILED BY A NUMBER OF LAW
PROFESSORS AROUND THE COUNTRY
WHO ARE SPECIALISTS AND
EMPLOYMENT LAW AND SEX
DISCRIMINATION LAW AND I THINK
MANY OF THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS --
WOULD BE EXTRAORDINARILY HELPFUL
TO YOU AS YOU ARE FASHIONING --
LEGISLATIVE --
INITIATIVES --
THEY ADDRESS MANY OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE TODAY --
I THINK CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF
THE STRONGER LAWS BUT THEY HAVE
IDEAS OR EVEN HOW TO STRENGTHEN --
THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE IN THIS
STATE AND I KNOW THEY WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
ON ANY --
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION THAT YOU
YOU WANTED TO PURSUE I AM
CERTAIN THAT THEY WOULD ITS A
VERY COMPREHENSIVE DOCUMENT.
I'M ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS --
THAT I THINK TO RECOGNIZE ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS THAT ONE
IT'S NOT ALWAYS SEXUAL IN NATURE.
BUT IT ALWAYS OCCURS IN GATED.
ASUS AND WHERE THERE IS
TREMENDOUS INEQUALITY AS MARIA
ELENA SAID --
IN THE EMPLOYMENT SITUATION AND
SO YOU CAN ONLY REALLY APPROACH --
ELIMINATING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IF
YOU'RE ALSO LOOKING AT HOW DO
YOU FORCE --
A DESEGREGATION WITHIN THE
WORKPLACE --
AT ALL LEVELS AND IN ALL
DIFFERENT --
INDUSTRIES IN ALL DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ORGANIZATIONS --
WOMEN ARE RELEGATED TO THE
LOWEST JOBS IN EVERY SECTOR --
AND MEN HAVE THE TOP JOBS IN
EVERY SEX AND IT IS --
IMBALANCED UP AT EVERY LEVEL
WOMEN ARE CONCENTRATED IN
CERTAIN TYPES OF JOBS AND THAT
JUST REINFORCES GENDER
STEREOTYPES.
IT REINFORCES --
THAT WOMEN ARE SECOND CLASS
CITIZENS IN THE WORKPLACE --
AND AUNTS AND IN MANY CASES --
ARE -- THERE --
TO PLEASE THEIR CUSTOMERS ARE CO
WORKERS WHO HAVE POWER OVER THEM --
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT --
WOMEN IN THE HOTEL INDUSTRY
WOMEN IN THE FOOD SERVICES
INDUSTRY --
THERE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE --
AND SO THE LAWS MUST REALLY
FOCUS ON HOW WE ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD --
THESE ARE SOME OF THEIR KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS --
THAT FEDERAL AND STATE
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND THEY
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN FORCES --
LAWS AGAINST SEX OUT
DISCRIMINATION THAT IN ADDITION --
TO JUST TAPPED TO CHALLENGING
THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT THAT WE
COMBINED A CHALLENGE TO THE SEX --
SEGREGATION AND THE STEREOTYPING
IN THE INEQUALITY IN THE WAY
WORKPLACES ARE STRUCTURE.
BOB BECAUSE ONLY WHEN WE HAVE
GENDER BALANCE AT EVERY LEVEL OF
EVERY ORGANIZATION WILL WE SEE --
SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
REALLY BEGIN TO DISAPPEAR AND
DISAPPEAR RAPIDLY --
THAT --
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW SHOULD
ALSO REQUIRE ORGANIZATIONS TO
ELIMINATE SEX SPECIFIC GROOMING
AND DRESS REQUIRE --
TO REQUIRE WAITRESSES --
TO WEAR SKIMPY OUTFITS TOM AND I
SUSPECT I I KNOW THAT MANY OF
THE HOTEL WORKERS UNIFORMS MAKE
IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
PERFORM THEIR JOBS --
IN A DIGNIFIED MANNER AND SO I
THE STATE --
COULD LOOK AT LEGISLATION IN
THAT WAY AS WELL UP THE UNIFORMS
SHOULD ONLY BE RELEVANT TO
WHATEVER IS ESSENTIAL AS PART OF
THE JOB DESCRIPTION.
I'M NOT --
TO CREATE A HETEROSEXUAL --
SEXUAL --
RETRACTION.
TO STEREOTYPE THAT WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE.
SAY OH LAWMAKERS IN AGENCIES
ALSO SHOULD LOOK AT HOW WE
CREATE INCENTIVES FOR
ORGANIZATIONS TO ELIMINATE
EMPLOYEE VULNERABILITIES --
IN THE WORKPLACE AND UNCHECK
SUPERVISORY AUTHORITY --
OBVIOUSLY --
PANIC BUTTONS IS ONE WAY TO DO
THAT THERE ARE MANY INNOVATIVE
WAYS TO DO IT WE HAVE ALL KINDS
OF STANDARDS AND THE FOOD
INDUSTRY --
HEALTH STANDARDS --
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE STANDARDS AND
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE ISSUES
THAT WOMEN ARE FACED WITH ON THE
JOB AS PART OF THEIR HEALTH?
AND THE HEALTH OF OUR SOCIETY SO
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THAT AS WELL --
OBVIOUSLY IS YOU PARTY HOOD --
HEARD A CONTRACT INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS HAVE TO BE COVERED
IN ALL INSTANCES MANY TIMES THE
LAW DOES NOT APPLY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TITLE SEVEN
DOESN'T APPLY --
OUT ESPECIALLY TO SMALLER
WORKPLACES ON THIS STATE OF
CALIFORNIA COULD BE VERY --
INNOVATIVE AND AND ADDRESSING
THAT ALSO THE STATE HAS
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC POWER WITH
RESPECT TO THE CONTRACTORS --
WHERE STATE EMPLOYEES ARE
ALLOWED THE HOTEL HAS MORE THAN
ONE COMPLAINT OF --
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR HARASSMENT
STATE EMPLOYEES SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO STAY --
IN THOSE HOTELS OR TO FREQUENT
THOSE RESTAURANTS I AND THIS AND
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE RIGHT TO
DEMAND THESE ARE OUR TAX DOLLARS
GAMESTOP.
I KNOW WITH RESPECT TO
RETALIATION ISSUES THIS LEGAL --
SKY STANFORD LAW REVIEW ARTICLE
HAS SOME VERY CONCRETE.
GESTIONES FOR HOW TO BETTER
PROTECT EMPLOYEES FROM --
FROM MY RECRIMINATION IN AND OUT
FROM RETALIATION --
AND AND THE LAW IS VERY
INADEQUATE RIGHT NOW IS IT
ADDRESSES --
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW COULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE BYSTANDER INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS ON THEIR PROVING VERY
VERY EFFECTIVE.
BY EMPOWERING EMPLOYEES TO STEP
FORWARD --
TO BEAR WITNESS TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AS THEY SEE IT AND AT
THEMSELVES NOT TO BECOME --
THE SUBJECT OF RETALIATION AND
SO.
WE WE SHOULD TAKE A CAREFUL LOOK
AT HOW THOSE LAWS ARE STRUCTURED.
A COUPLE FINAL --
POINTS IS THAT FEDERAL AND STATE
HAVE TO DEFINE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IS BEING --
DE EMPLOYER BEING SUBJECT TO
STRICT LIABILITY UNDER FEDERAL
LAW EMPLOYERS ARE NOT. TO STRICT
LIABILITY --
UNDER I I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA LAW BUT EMPLOYERS
HAVE TO BE FINANCIALLY AND
OTHERWISE LIABLE FOR THE
HARASSMENT CARRIED OUT IN THEIR
WORKPLACES WHETHER IT'S BY A
SUPERVISOR OR CO WORKER OUR
CUSTOMER.
AND THEN FINALLY --
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS --
SHOULD JOB GET RID OF MANDATORY
ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT.
SO.
YOU KNOW TO SUMMARIZE THERE
THERE ARE MANY DIFFERENT ASPECTS
OF OUR APPOINTMENTS --
WORK PLACES THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED IT REALLY BEGAN TO
DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM OF
PERVASIVE IN WIDESPREAD SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE'VE GOT TO
RESTRUCTURE OUR WORKPLACES SO
THAT --
THEY'RE NO LONGER SEGREGATED BY
GENDER -- AT
ANY LEVEL --
THAT'S VERY VERY KEY IN
CALIFORNIA COULD DO A LOT
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH. ONE OF ON A PERSONAL NOTE
WE ALWAYS LIKE TO SHOUT OUT TO
GETTING RID OF BY.
LIMON I THINK ALMOST EVERYBODY
IS A CO AUTHOR HAVE TELL.
GOOD GOOD EVENING.
THANK YOU A CHAIR GONZALEZ
FLETCHER FOR HAVING ME HERE AND
THE ENTIRE SELECT COMMITTEE --
MIKE SPIT MY NAME IS MONICA YOU
SEVEN ATTORNEY --
I PRACTICE UNION SIDE LABOR LAW.
AND PLAINTIFF'S EMPLOYMENT LAW A
TRADITION I HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
IMMIGRANT WORKER RIGHTS --
OUT MY EXPERIENCE IN THE AREA OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT HAS BEEN
PRIMARILY AROUND --
WORKING WITH LOW WAGE WORKERS
IMMIGRANT WORKERS --
REPRESENTING WORKERS BOTH
INDIVIDUALLY AS PLAINTIFFS IN
LAWSUITS AS WELL AS THEIR UNIONS --
I REPRESENT VARIOUS UNIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY INCLUDING
OF THE PROPERTY SERVICE WORKERS
A JANITOR'S UNION U. S. W. W..
I'M IN ADDITION TO THAT I DO
HAVE.
EXPERIENCE WITH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN NON LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES WHERE WE HAVE --
SITUATIONS WHERE I'VE HAD TO
PARTICIPATE AS AN INVESTIGATOR
AND IN THOSE INSTANCES --
IN ADDITION TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN
WITH LOW WAGE WORKERS WE ALSO
SEE THAT --
WOMEN IN THOSE INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE NOT TRADITIONAL LOW WAGE
INDUSTRIES --
FEAR THE SAME OF FAILURE TO
REPORT THEY ARE AFRAID TO REPORT
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT REPORTING
WILL RESULT IN RETALIATION.
AND OFTENTIMES THAT RETALIATION
MEANS -- AND
RESULTS IN IMPEDIMENTS TO PUBLIC
CONTINUING --
IN PROMOTING THEIR COULD HAVE
CAREER OR BEING ABLE TO OBTAIN
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES.
AND SO I'M I'M WAS GOING TO
DISCUSS JUST FIVE ISSUES I HOPE
I CAN GET TO THEM ALL.
THAT WE SEE RECURRING IN TERMS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND TO
THINK ABOUT POLICIES THAT WOULD
ASSIST IN PREVENTING SEXUAL HER --
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT IN THE
WORKPLACE.
I'M AND THE THE FIRST WOULD BE
TIME TO GET --
TO THE POINT OF THE FAILURE TO
REPORT AND TRYING TO FIND
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ACTUALLY
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF WHY IS IT
THAT WOMEN ARE FREE TO COME
FORWARD WE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IMPACTS ALL GENDERS SO IT'S NOT
JUST WOMEN.
BUT IT'S THE FEAR AS WE HEARD
FROM THE WOMEN WHO TESTIFIED.
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON.
THE FEAR OF LOSING THEIR JOB THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE CHILDREN
THAT THEY NEED TO SUPPORT.
THE FEAR OF RETALIATION IN OTHER
FORMS NOT JUST LOSING JOBS WHAT
OTHER FORMS AS I MENTIONED IN
TERMS OF BLOCKING THEIR ABILITY
TO FURTHER PROMOTE.
BLOCKING OPPORTUNITIES EVEN WITH
ANOTHER EMPLOYER.
I'M HOW TO ENCOURAGE REPORTING
WHAT TYPE OF POLICY AND
LEGISLATION --
COULD BE ENACTED TO SUPPORT
WOMEN TO BE ABLE TO COME FORWARD
TO REPORT.
EDUCATION AND TRAINING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT --
AND AS OF THE CHAIRS LAW
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL TRAINING IN THE
JANITORIAL SECTOR IN THE YEAH
LAST TIME BUT WHAT DOES HAVE
DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB IN TERMS
OF BUT WORKING WITH THIS.
DIFFERENT MODEL TO EDUCATE
WORKERS IN INDUSTRIES.
A MODEL THAT'S BASED ON THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MOVEMENT.
A MODEL THAT FOCUSES ON BREAKING
DOWN BARRIERS --
WITHIN OUR CULTURE AND SOCIETY
UP WITHIN OUR FAMILIES PART OF
THE REASON THAT OF MANY OF LOW
WAGE WORKERS IN PARTICULAR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS --
PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT CULTURES DO
NOT COME FORWARD IN TERMS OF
REPORTING IS BECAUSE THE WAY
WOMEN ARE TREATED IN SOCIETY.
THEY FEEL THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TOO MANY WOMEN --
AS THE PROBLEM DOES HAVE LEARNED
IN DOING THIS WORK.
REALIZE THAT THROUGH THIS
EDUCATION THEY DON'T EVEN
REALIZE THAT WHAT THEY WERE
EXPERIENCING WAS ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
WAS IN FACT GREAT.
AND SO THIS EDUCATION TALKING TO
WORKERS IN THE LANGUAGE THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
AT WE HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS ARE
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO EDUCATE
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
YET THERE IS NOT MUCH OF A
CHANGE AND I THINK.
YOUR GROUNDBREAKING LEGISLATION
IN TERMS OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AND HOPEFULLY THE
INNOVATIVE --
TRAINING WITH RESPECT APPEAR
TRAINERS IN THE WORKPLACE OR YOU
COULD HAVE WORKERS WHO COME OUT.
CAN TALK TO WORKERS IN A
LANGUAGE THEY UNDERSTAND IN A
TRAUMA INFORMED TRAINING WORKERS
WHO ARE SURVIVORS WHO HAVE BEEN
THERE TO BE ABLE TO ENCOURAGE
WOMEN TO COME FORWARD AND FEEL
THAT THEY ARE SUPPORTED AND KNOW
THAT THEY CAN REPORT.
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION --
THE SECOND ISSUE I WANT TO
DISCUSS IS IN FACT RETALIATION
AND WE HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS ON
RETALIATION AND AND BUT YET IT'S
INEVITABLE AND IT STILL HAPPENS.
AND ONE OF THE ISSUES WITH
RETALIATION IS THAT IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PROVE.
IT'S OFTEN HE SAID SHE SAID OR
HE SAID HE SAID OR SHE SAID SHE
SAID AND HAVING THINGS LIKE THE
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION WITCHES
AND AND I UNDERSTAND OF PENDING
LEGISLATION.
A WOULD BE HELPFUL BUT I THINK
POLICIES THAT WOULD GET AT
TRYING TO FIND WAYS TO ENSURE
THAT RETALIATION IS.
PREVENTED NOT ONLY PROHIBITED
BUT LOOKING AT WAYS TO ENSURE
THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE
IT DOES.
AND IN MANY WAYS --
THE NEXT WOULD BE A SHIFT
CULTURES IN THE WORKPLACE --
AND THIS IS SOMEWHAT TIED TO
THESE NON DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS
THAT THAT --
MANY EMPLOYERS OFTEN SIGN WHEN A
WORKER COMES FOR TO COMPLAINTS
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
SO YOU HAVE REPEAT OFFENDERS WHO
ENGAGE IN THIS CONDUCT.
YOU HAVE THE PROBLEM WITH THE
FAILURE TO REPORT.
YOU HAVE A FEAR OF RETALIATION
AND THEN THE ACTUAL RETALIATION
BECAUSE IT DOES HAPPEN
INEVITABLY IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY IT WILL HAPPEN DOWN
THE ROAD.
AND FAILURE TO REPORT
IMMEDIATELY AFTER SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
YOU REPORT IT LATER THERE IS
STILL GOING TO BE SOME FORM OF
RETALIATION.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS IS THAT
YOU YOU YOU HAVE TO SITUATIONS
THE EMPLOYER SIGNS AN AGREEMENT.
PROMISES YOU KNOW THE WORKER IT
WON'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
CONFIDENTIALITY NO ONE CAN TALK
ABOUT IT AND THEN THERE'S TWO
THINGS THAT HAPPEN EITHER THAT.
THAT PERSON WAS TERMINATED AND
THEY MOVE ON TO ANOTHER EMPLOYER
IN THE NEW EMPLOYER HAS NO IDEA.
THAT THIS PERSON ENGAGED IN THIS
TYPE OF BEHAVIOR AND SO NOW
THEY'VE HIRED SOMEONE WHO
POTENTIALLY IS GOING TO BE A
REPEAT OFFENDER --
OR NUMBER TWO THEY KEEP THAT
PERSON EMPLOYED AND THEY KEEP
WORKING TO COME TO CONTINUE TO
REPEAT THAT BEHAVIOR BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT EVERYTHING'S
CONFIDENTIAL AND YOU CAN'T
DISCUSS THE FACT THAT IT EVER
HAPPENED.
OR THE TERMS OF THE AGREEMENT OR
THAT THERE EVER WAS AN AGREEMENT
THAT WAS REACHED --
IN FACT MANY OF THESE AGREEMENTS
IN ORDER FOR A YOU KNOW A
COMPLAINING OF VICTIM TO BE ABLE
TO OBTAIN THIS INFORMATION --
BUT TO BE ABLE TO TO SETTLE THIS
CASE AGAINST AN EMPLOYER THEY'RE
PROHIBITED FROM SAYING ANYTHING
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN ANY TYPE OF
RELIEF.
AND I SEE THAT MY TIME IS UP I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT --
THE ONLY OTHER TWO THINGS I
WANTED TO MENTION WAS JUST UP
THE ISSUE OF HOLDING EMPLOYERS
ACCOUNTABLE.
OF IN THESE LOW WAGE INDUSTRIES
WE DO HAVE LOTS OF
SUBCONTRACTORS SO OBVIOUSLY
JOINT LIABILITY IS IMPORTANT.
AND FINAL POINT UNIONIZATION IS
OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT WAY TO
PREVENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
GOOD EVENING I'M CARRY WOULD
UNITS AND DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS THAT SAG AFTRA AND OUR
PRESIDENT GABRIELLE CAR TERRACE
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE WITH YOU
TONIGHT SHE SENDS OUR DEEPEST
REGRETS AND NOW YOU'RE STUCK
WITH ME INSTEAD BUT THANK YOU
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE --
LET ME START BY THINKING THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO HAVE STEPPED
FORWARD TO ADDRESS ISSUE OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
HARAP HARASSMENT HAPPENS IN ALL
INDUSTRIES BUT BECAUSE OF THE
PUBLIC NATURE OF OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY THERE'S
BEEN A LIGHT SHONE ON ON OUR
MEMBERS IN PARTICULAR --
INSIDE AFTER AS A UNION FOUNDED
IN FORCE --
WE BELIEVE IN TERMS OF SOLUTIONS
THERE'S A CULTURAL CHANGE NATIVE
AND THERE'S ALSO STRENGTHENED
STRENGTHENING OF THE LAWS --
A COUPLE OF THESE BILLS ARE
CURRENTLY MOVING THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE SUPPORT. TO
BETTER PROTECT OUR MEMBERS --
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
SENATORS HANNAH BETH JACKSON AND
CONNIE LEYVA --
AND IT JUST A COUPLE OF TO
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE IDEAS THAT WE
SUPPORT --
TO PROTECT OUR OUR SITE AFTER
MEMBERS ARE EXPANDING MANDATORY
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING IN
THE WORKFORCE --
LIMITING THE ABILITY OF
EMPLOYERS TO FORCE EMPLOYEES TO
SIGN NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS AS
A CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT --
PROHIBITING EMPLOYERS FROM
RETALIATING AGAINST VICTIMS OR
WITNESSES --
LIMITING THE ABUSE OF FORCED
ARBITRATION --
PROVISIONS AS THEY APPLY TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CASES --
AND ALSO PROHIBITING SECRET
SETTLEMENTS --
CASES UNLESS THE VICTIM WANTS IT
SECRET MRS BEEN ACUTE ISSUE AS
YOU KNOW IN IN ENTERTAINMENT --
I JUST LIKE TO TOUCH ON A FEW
THINGS THAT WE AS THE UNION ARE
DOING -- TO
HELP OUR MEMBERS AND TO SHIELD
THEM FROM THESE ISSUES OF
HARASSMENT --
OUR EFFORTS INCLUDE A MEMBER
EDUCATION THROUGH INDUSTRY
PANELS -- WE
HELD ONE LAST SEPTEMBER WITH
GLORIA ALLRED AT OUR OFFICES --
WE ALSO HAD A MEMBERS ONLY
BRIEFING IN MARCH WITH SENATORS
AYE LEYVA AND JACKSON --
AND WE'VE ESTABLISHED SOMETHING
CALLED --
GUIDELINE NUMBER ONE WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT AND IT --
BANDS AUDITIONS IN HOTEL ROOMS
AND PRIVATE RESIDENCES.
SO THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT FOR
OUR MEMBERS --
YEAH.
YEAH AND ALSO ESTABLISHED A CODE
OF CONDUCT --
OUR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT --
AT CONTAINS VERY EXPLICIT
PROVISIONS GOVERNING WORKPLACE
RULES AND SAFETY AROUND SEX
SCENES --
BUT WE'RE GOING THE EXTRA STEP --
WE'RE INCREASING THE UNIONS
CAPACITY.
SUPPORT MEMBERS TO FACE
HARASSMENT --
THE FARM MEMBERS WE NEED TO MAKE
REPORT WE HAVE A TWENTY FOUR
HOUR HOTLINE THEY CAN CALL WE
INVESTIGATE ALL THE COMPLAINTS
WE RECEIVE --
AND RESPOND IMMEDIATELY --
THAT'S THE A BRIEF SORT OF
SNAPSHOT INCLUDING I JUST WANTED
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE --
WE BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW UNIONS
HAVE TO STICK TOGETHER IN THIS
FIGHT --
WE'RE PLEASED TO HAVE A SEAT AT
THIS TABLE --
AND BECAUSE OF THE COURAGE AND
HARD WORK OF SO MANY LAWMAKERS
ARE UNION LEADERS AND ACTIVISTS --
THE NEXT GENERATION LINE TERRA
DIFFERENT WORK ENVIRONMENT THANK
YOU.
INTERESTED IN NOW AS A
LEGISLATOR AS A NEW LEGISLATOR --
I ALSO THOUGHT OF CATHY --
THE STANDARDS THAT YOU MENTION
YOU KNOW WE HAVE HEALTH
STANDARDS ARE RESTAURANTS HAVE A
LETTER.
BASED ON YOU KNOW HOW CLEANERS
YOU KNOW HOW.
THEY'RE KEEPING US YOU KNOW TO
THOSE STANDARDS YOU KNOW WHY
CAN'T EMPLOYERS HAVE THAT WE
SHOULD KNOW --
EVERYBODY THAT IS POTENTIALLY
TAKING A JOB OR DOING BUSINESS.
PER SHOULD KNOW THEIR RECORDS ON
ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND AND
EVALUATE SO THAT'S SOMETHING.
I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE AN IDEA
OF WHAT TYPE OF STANDARDS.
THAT SHOULD BE THAT'S A QUESTION.
JUST YEAH I THE ONE THING THAT
COMES TO MIND IMMEDIATELY IS
UNIFORMS --
WHY SHOULD?
WOMEN ARE WORKING AS WAIT STAFF --
BE FORCED IN MANY CASES TO WEAR
UNIFORMS THAT ARE MEANT TO BE
SEXUALLY ATTRACTIVE TO MALE
CUSTOMERS OR TO THE MALE MANAGER --
AND AND THAT'S JUST ONE ASPECT
OF IT --
CLEARLY THERE MAY BE OTHER WAYS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE --
STANDARDS IN THE WORKPLACE ALSO.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT TO BE ABLE
TO WEAR UNIFORM THAT THAT ALLOWS
YOU TO DO YOUR JOB EFFICIENTLY
AND WITHOUT FEAR THAT --
IT'S GOING TO BE AN INVITATION
FOR THE CUSTOMER TO GRAB YOUR
* SO --
AND DOES DOES THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT I WAS THINKING OF WHEN I
SEE [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU ALL FOR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS YOU CERTAINLY PROVIDED.
UNDER RAY HAVE DIFFERENT IDEAS
ON BOTH POLICY IDEAS AND THEN
LEGISLATIVE IDEAS AND I DO HAVE
A QUESTION IN THINKING ABOUT.
THE LAWS THAT CURRENTLY ARE IN
PLACE AND A COUPLE OF YOU
MENTIONED ENFORCEMENT OR LACK
THEREOF.
THAT CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
MORE TO THAT IF YOU KNOW WHAT
WILL IT TAKE.
I WHETHER IT'S FROM AN
EMPLOYER'S PERSPECTIVE OR FROM
THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE TO
ENFORCE THE CURRENT LAWS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE THAT ARE SUPPOSED
TO PROTECT.
WORKERS AT THIS MOMENT WHAT IS
IT WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK LIKE.
BUT I THINK OF AS SOON AS WE
KNOW UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
LAWS THAT GOVERN IS THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING ACT.
AND THERE IS ONLY.
REALLY A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
SO IT'S NOT --
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THERE IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
AND WE HAVE AN EXCELLENT
DIRECTOR AND KEVIN KISH.
BUT THE AGENCY'S ROLE AND
FUNCTION IS TO TAKE THE
COMPLAINTS WITHIN THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS THEY CAN CONDUCT --
AN INVESTIGATION IF THEY CHOOSE
TO OF I THINK IT --
IN SOME CASES THEY ARE
LITIGATING BUT THEY ARE NOT
OBLIGATED TO TAKE ANY CASE TO
COURT.
AND MORE OFTEN THAN NOT THEY
WILL THEN THEY MAY CONDUCT THEY
CONDUCT WHAT MANY MORE
INVESTIGATIONS NOW THE ISSUE
RIGHT TO SUE LETTERS AND THEN
THE WORKER HAS TO GO OUT AND
FIND THEIR OWN.
ATTORNEY TO FILE A LAWSUIT.
AND I THINK YOUR QUESTION IS ONE
THAT -- NON
ATTORNEY ADVOCATES HAVE BEEN
REALLY DISCUSSING FOR AWHILE YOU
KNOW IT IN THEIR MINDS I THINK
YOU KNOW OF A LOT OF WORKER
RIGHTS FOLKS DO A LOT OF YOUR
TRADITIONAL.
MAYBE WAGING OUR LABOR
VIOLATIONS WHERE YOU GO TO THE
STATE AND THE STATE ENFORCES
THOSE LAWS.
AND I KNOW THAT WORKER ADVOCATES
WOULD LIKE SOMETHING SIMILAR IN
THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
ARENA -- AND
AND I AND I DIRECTOR I'M BUT I
THINK THE WAY THE LAW IS SET UP
NOW AND THE THE ENFORCEMENT IS
THROUGH PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
AND SO I THINK --
IT IN TERMS OF OF OF ENFORCEMENT
IT IT HAS TO BE THE INDIVIDUAL
ON THEIR OWN FINDING AN ATTORNEY
TO ENFORCE THE LAW AND TO AND TO
SPEND TO SUE AN EMPLOYER --
AYE AT IN TERMS OF A DETERRENT
EFFECT ON EMPLOYERS I MEAN I
THINK.
YOU KNOW THE PENALTIES OR
PUNITIVE DAMAGES OR THEIR YOU
KNOW A WORKER CAN GET DAMAGES.
OF NOT ONLY THEIR ECONOMIC BUT
PAIN AND SUFFERING --
SO.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT MIGHT
BE AT THIS POINT IS THE ONLY
DETERRENT THE THE THE ADDITIONAL
OBLIGATIONS THAT YOU PLACE ON
EMPLOYERS IN THE FACT THAT THEY
COULD BE SUBJECT --
TO ADDITIONAL DAMAGES BUT
OTHERWISE IF YOU WANTED THE
STATE TO ENFORCE YOU'D HAVE.
TO REWRITE THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
SO YOU KNOW I JUST I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT BECAUSE THIS
IS AN ON GOING. THIRTY EIGHTY
ONE IN A NUMBER OF OTHER BILLS
WE TRIED --
TO GOD BLESS BE HAVE BUT COMING
FROM LABOR MOVEMENT I WANT
EVERYTHING A LABOR CODE --
WE WERE ATTEMPTING TO TO PUT
SOME OF THIS INTO THE LABOR CODE
AND ARE GETTING A LOT OF PUSH
BACK DO YOU THINK THAT WE HAVE
TO ACTUALLY RE WRITE ALL OF THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
CLAIMS OR COULD WE DO SOME OF
THE RETALIATION SOME OF THE
INITIAL RETALIATION [INAUDIBLE]
AND JOINT LIABILITY THINGS THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH AND PUT THEM
INTO.
THE LABOR CODE INSTEAD OF FEET
UP AS SMEARING THE HAT AS A WAY
TO ALLOW --
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
IF WE FUNDED A BETTER TO
ACTUALLY --
AND FOR SOME OF THESE OR ARE WE
JUST OPENED UP A PANDORA'S BOX.
WELL I I MEAN I DON'T WORK AT
THE DMV AGE SO I'M NOT I I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEIR POSITION IS BUT
I THINK THE THE IF I WORKED AT
THE AT AT AT THE DEALERS HERE OR
IF I WERE THE LABOR COMMISSIONER.
ABOUT WHAT I WOULD THINK IS MY
EXPERTISE IS ENFORCING THE LABOR
CODE WHICH IS THE WAGE AND HOUR
LAWS AND THE D. F. B. H. AND
EXPERTISE AS SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND HAS BEEN SO.
UP I'M SURE THAT THERE MAY BE A
WHICH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER MAY
BE ABLE TO ENFORCE --
APPROVED PROVISIONS RELATED TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT LIKE IT DOES
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IT
MEAN IT IS A REGISTRY.
THAT REQUIRE YOU KNOW THE THE
JANITORIAL CONTRACTORS ARE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER OF WITH OF
THE DLC WITH THE DIR AND THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER HAS POWER TO
ENFORCE THOSE PROVISIONS OF OF
OF NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND IT
REQUIRES THIS TRAINING PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING DEVELOPED WITH THE
AGENCY -- SO
YOU DO HAVE THAT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT NOW IN PLACE WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER I THINK THE ISSUE
REALLY COMES DOWN TO IF YOU DO
ANY ANYTHING MORE THAN THAT IS
THAT.
WHO HAS THE EXPERTISE IN THE
AREA AND AND IN TERMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION
LAWS?
IT IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING AS OPPOSED TO
THE LABOR COMMISSION.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD TO THAT.
I THINK STRENGTHENING MECHANISMS
FOR ENFORCEMENT IS VERY KEY FOR
REALLY GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF
ALL THIS NOT ONLY FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT BUT FOR OTHER TYPES
OF SEX DISCRIMINATION.
TO FOR DISCRIMINATION IN HIRING
AND PROMOTION AND PAY AND AS
THESE -- THE
STANFORD LAW REVIEW ARTICLE
POINTS OUT TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THE TWO GO HAND IN HAND YOU
DON'T GET A WORKPLACE --
THAT IS NOT ENGAGING IN OTHER
TYPES OF SEXUAL DISCRIMINATION --
YOU ALSO GET THAT THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS PART AND PARCEL OF
BANNING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
DISCRIMINATION --
AND SO STRENGTHENING THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO ENFORCE WHETHER
THAT'S AND I TIME NOT AN
ATTORNEY SO I I CAN'T.
SAY IN TERMS OF THE TERMINATION
LAWS OF THE LABOR LAWS BUT I
THINK IT'S WORTH TAKING A HARD
LOOK BECAUSE UNTIL WE BEGAN --
TO ENSURE THAT WOMEN ARE NOT
RELEGATED TO ONLY THE LOWEST
POSITIONS IN THE LOWEST PAY AND
SEGREGATED IN THE WORKPLACE.
WE CAN'T REALLY GET IT.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OVERALL --
I JUST I DON'T WANT TO MENTION
THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF AND SALAS
FLETCHER.
THAT I SAW THE CONNECTION BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT YOU PASSED WITH
THE JANITORS.
AND WHAT THEY HAVE IMPLEMENTED.
WHAT THEY IMPLEMENTED WAS
ENFORCEMENT?
THE PROMOTE BOUGHT US.
I THINK THERE'S GOT TO BE
ANOTHER WAY OF ENFORCING AND NOT
ONLY TO RELY ON HOW MANY.
INSPECTORS THE STATE HIRES
BECAUSE WILL NEVER DO IT'LL
NEVER HAPPEN.
AND I'M SURE IT'S A SOURCE OF
FRUSTRATION FOR MANY OF YOU WHO
PASSED THESE GOOD LAWS IS THAT
THEY SIT ON THE BOOKS AND
MEANWHILE EVERY SINGLE DAY
THERE'S HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF VIOLATION SO.
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK
OF I MEAN AS YOU PASS THESE LAWS
WHO IS IT CONNECTED WITH.
THAT WILL HELP ENFORCE.
IF I THINK FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
THERE IS A WAY --
FOR EXPERTS ON IN CONSTRUCTION
TO GO IN AND THEN FORCE AND THEY
HAVE TO BE RESPECTED AND AND
ALLOWED ONTO THE PROPERTY --
BY THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN SORT OF I
DON'T KNOW [INAUDIBLE]
DEPUTIZED.
BUT THERE'S GOT BE A WAY OF
DEPUTISING.
A LOT MORE PEOPLE OR IT'S NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN AND WE'RE GOING
TO BE.
FEELING GREAT BECAUSE WE PASSED
THE LAW AND THEY'RE STILL --
THOUSANDS OF VIOLATIONS.
I WOULD ADD MAKE ANOTHER WOULD
BE.
TO I MEAN ONE OF THE ISSUES WITH
THE F. B. AGE AND THE FACT THAT
THERE IS ONLY A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION IS THAT THEY HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES TO TAKE CASES TO COURT.
SO IF IF WE'RE LOOKING AT AN
EASIER FIX ON STATE IN FORCE AND
THAT DOESN'T CHANGE THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'D
BE DOING AYE I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
HAD THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH
ADVOCATES ON HOW TO DO THAT --
IT WOULD BE FUNDING DFB AGE THAT
THEY CAN HIRE MORE LAWYERS TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE MORE CASES TO COURT
I MEAN THAT SEEMS TO ME LIKE.
THE EASIER ALL THE FIXES BUT ONE
THING WE'D LIKE TO SEE A LOOK
THAT IS --
EXTENDING THE LAW TO PROTECTS
WORKERS FROM PREDATORS WHO HOLD
THEMSELVES OUT.
AS AS BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE A
JOB SO WHEN YOU GO ON AN
INTERVIEW OR IN ADDITION.
THERE'S NO DIRECT EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP AT THAT MOMENT IN
OUR INDUSTRY WHEN YOU GO ON AN
AUDITION THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
THESE OFFENSES ARE BEING
COMMITTED.
SO WE'D LIKE THERE TO BE SOME
SOME LOOKING INTO TO HOW WE CAN
EXPAND TO COVER THAT AS WELL.
I DID BUT I DID WANT TO REMIND.
I WAS JUST REMINDED THAT THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS DID REQUEST AN
ADDITIONAL THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
THE FDA'S TO DO TO HIRE MORE
INVESTIGATORS.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE ENOUGH BUT
WE DO KNOW THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
SIZE A PRIORITY THEY DID
REQUESTED IN SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET.
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
BEING HERE BECAUSE I'M JUST
REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF ALL THE
INFORMATION WE'RE TAKING AN
WHICH IS PART OF OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
BUT AS AN EDUCATOR FOR THIRTY
YEARS UP LEARNING THE
INFORMATION IS IMPORTANT BUT
THAT ACTUALLY TAKING THAT.
OUT TO WHERE WE NEED TO IS AS
IMPORTANT LIKE YOU SAY WE PASSED
MANY MANY LAWS SOMETIMES THERE --
WE IN THE WEEDS IF YOU WANT TO
SAY THAT LEGISLATORS ARE REALLY
THE ONLY ONES WHO KNOW ABOUT IT.
AND SO ONE OF MY SITES IS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW TO IN FOUR
HOURS AND HOW TO ADD ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO REALLY USE THE HAMMER
AS WE KNOW SOMETIMES WE NEED.
TO BUT I WANTED TO FLIP THE
EQUATION AND FIND OUT IS THEIR
WORK BEING DONE ON THE EDUCATION
PART I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THE
PROMONTORY IS ALREADY WHEN
PEOPLE ARE ADULTS BUT MUCH OF
THIS -- AYE
EVERYONE OF US OUT UNLESS I HAVE
TWO YOUNG ADULT SONS --
WHETHER WERE ANSWER GRANDMOTHERS
ARE SISTERS.
AND I WOULD NOT WANT TO SUGGEST
WE SHOULD BE DOING THIS IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BECAUSE AS A
TEACHER.
WE KEEP LAYERING AND LAYERING
THE SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
DEPRESSION ABUSE AND TEACHERS
CAN READ IT OUT WE HAD YET
ANOTHER THING --
THAT THERE'S MANY THINGS TO
EDUCATION BUT EVEN SOME TYPE OF
CAMPAIGN OR THE SERIES THAT CAN
BE TAKEN DIRECTLY TO THE PUBLIC
WHETHER IT'S ON FACEBOOK WHETHER
IT'S IN UNIONS BUT TO MOTHERS
AND TO FATHERS.
OF HOW DO YOU TALK TO YOUR SONS
AND DAUGHTERS BECAUSE LIKE YOU
SAY IT'S NOT JUST WHAT.
ABOUT HOW DO YOU NOT ONLY
RESPECT WOMEN BUT HOW DO YOU
RESPECT EACH OTHER BECAUSE THIS
IS A LARGER CONVERSATION.
THAT THE THEMES ARE ABOUT RACISM
THE THEMES ARE ABOUT --
NOT ONLY SEXUAL HARASSMENT BUT
ABOUT ABUSE THINGS ABOUT WHEN WE
LOOK AT OUR TOP LEADERSHIP IN
THE UNITED STATES AND AND YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE WATCHING THAT EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND THEY SAY WELL IF
HE CAN DO WHAT I CAN DO IT.
WHEN WE SEE IT DISMISSED AND A
VERY LIGHT HEARTED WAY THAT NO
THIS JUST DOESN'T HAPPEN?
SO I WHILE I WOULD LOVE TO BE
PART OF THE WAY TO REALLY WORK
ON THIS SO WE CAN GET TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD SO WE CAN GET LIKE YOU
SAY WHETHER IT'S TOYS ARE THE
WAY I ONE PERSON THAT I RESPECT --
FOR TRULY IS --
FROM ORANGE COUNTY HUMAN
RELATIONS --
A RUSTY KENNEDY WHO ONCE SAID
MANY YEARS AGO BEFORE --
SOME OF THESE TOPICS HAVE
EMERGED TO THIS LEVEL WAS WHEN
YOU SEE RACISM WHEN YOU STAND BY
AND WATCH IT YOU'RE JUST AS
GUILTY.
SO IT'S LIKE THE BYSTANDERS
WHETHER IT'S THE CHILD ON THE
SCHOOL YARD OR THEN EMERGES TO
JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH SCHOOL AND
YOU SEE YOUNG KIDS FILMING.
THESE HATEFUL INCIDENTS WHETHER
IT'S HARASSMENTS OR EVEN MORE
RATE.
THIS IS A CULTURAL ISSUE HOW DID
WE GET HERE AND WHAT DO WE DO TO
EDUCATE TO GET OUT OF THAT.
WE NEED TO HAMMER FOR
ENFORCEMENT BUT LET'S TURN IT
AROUND AND START LOOKING AT
PREVENTION.
ACTUALLY SCHOOLS HAVE THE NOVEL
TITLE --
NINE BOTH FEDERAL AND STATE --
TO ELIMINATE A HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT FOR THEIR STUDENTS
AND AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS ONE
OF THEM [INAUDIBLE]
THERE.
SO -- AGAIN
I MEAN CALIFORNIA HAS A GREAT
TITLE NINE LAW --
THE QUESTION IS --
IS MONEY BEING ALLOCATED FOR
ENFORCEMENT --
AND AND IT IS AN OBLIGATION OF
TEACHERS OF ADMINISTRATORS OF
PRINCIPLES AND ALL UP THE CHAIN
NAM IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
THAT THEY HAVE GOT TO BE.
PRE VENTING --
DISCRIMINATION AND HARASSMENT AS
WELL AS DEALING WITH IT WHEN
THEY SEE IT THEY ALREADY HAVE AN
OBLIGATION WE WE SHOULD DIE PUT
MORE.
PRESSURE AND RESOURCES IN THAT
DIRECTION.
TO YOU THINK YOU KNOW MY ALMOST
FELT LIKE --
MISS QUIRK SILVA RIGHT OFF OF MY
MY THOUGHTS COULDN'T A LOT OF
MONEY.
A LOT OF MY FEELINGS TO WERE
ABOUT A CULTURAL CHANGE IN IN
NIGHT RECOGNIZE THAT THE FACT
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO.
PARTICULAR WHEN YOU HAVE
ADMINISTRATION THAT'S GONE AWAY
WITH LANGUAGE THAT I I CAN'T
UNDERSTAND TO THIS DAY HOW
THERE'S A DOUBLE STANDARD IN
THAT BUT HAVING SAID THAT.
YUMMY COURAGE TO KNOW THAT WE
CAN DO AT THIS POINT IN TIME
THINGS THAT WE THOUGHT WERE
IMPOSSIBLE.
A YEARS AGO --
WHEN THIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
FIRST PROPOSED CO AUTHOR HERE I
COULDN'T GET THE VOTES?
I MEAN IT WAS THAT SIMPLE AND
THAT HARD.
THAT PEOPLE REALLY.
PEOPLE IN OUR HOUSE REALLY
THOUGHT THAT IT WAS GOING TO FAR
TO GET THE VOTES TO PREVENT RAPE
THAT WORKED I MEAN WE COULD EVEN
BELIEVE SITTING ON THE FLOOR
THAT THAT THAT WE WERE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION.
AND SO WE'VE NOW GOT THIS
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO GET THINGS
THROUGH THAT WE COULD SEE
POSSIBLE.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T SAID THAT.
WHAT I STRUGGLE WITH IT AND WE
PASS?
AND IT'S BEEN SAID BEFORE WE
PASS LAWS AND IF YOU TOOK A LOOK
AT ALL THE LAWS THAT WE PASSED
ALREADY NONE OF IT SHOULD BE
HAVING A MAYBE EVEN COMMON SENSE
WOULD TELL YOU THAT THIS SHOULD
NOT HAPPENING AND WE DON'T.
WE DO NOT TOLERATE IT.
AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE WE HAVE TO
KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT ENFORCING
LAWS WHEN NONE OF THIS SHOULD BE
HAPPENING TO BEGIN WITH I THINK
WILL AGREE WITH THAT.
AND SO I WONDER IS THERE
SOMETHING ELSE IN PARTICULAR
WITH INDUSTRIES WHERE WE KNOW
THIS IS PROBABLY.
AND ALSO BE SPECIFICALLY TO
MAYBE LOWER WAGE EARNERS WHERE
YOU DON'T KNOW YOUR RIGHTS --
YOU DON'T KNOW THE LANGUAGE FEAR
DEPORTATION WE SEE THIS OUR
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE SOMETHING
ALL STRUCTURED IN ABOUT IT INTO
THE BUSINESS LICENSE OUR
BUSINESS MODEL BEFORE YOU ENTER --
THIS A PARTICULAR INDUSTRY --
TO SAY THAT YOU HAVE TO GET
BONDED PREFERRED THIS IN CASE
THIS HAPPENS BECAUSE THE ONLY
WAY TO DETER SOMEBODY NAY AGREES
WITH THE STIFFER PENALTIES AND
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
STILL.
THAT HAVE TO BE THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE CAN DO THAT I WANTED
MUCH HAS BEEN GIVEN TO THOUGHT.
WHERE WHERE THAT WHERE WE HAVE
TO DO CULTURAL CHANGE BUT DO IT
ON THE FRONT END SO THAT WE HOPE
THAT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN ON THE
BACKING THAT WERE CATCHING
PEOPLE?
COULD YOU IMAGINE A SYSTEM WHERE
THERE'S AND I I DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT WOULD BE RIGHT BUT HELP ME
THINK --
UPON SET UP IN THE IN THESE
PARTICULAR INDUSTRIES A
DIFFERENT SORT OF LICENSE AND
INSURANCE OR SOMETHING STRICTER.
BUT REGISTRY OR SOMETHING ON THE
FRONT END SO THAT WE WE ATTACK
IT.
ON AND IT DOESN'T HAPPEN SOME
THESE LOW WAGE INCOME --
INDUSTRIES ONE IF.
YOU CAN HELP ME WITH THAT.
I THINK WE JUST GOT A TAKE A
LOOK AT SOME INNOVATIVE.
WAYS OF APPROACHING THAT WHETHER
IT IS THROUGH LICENSING --
THROUGH OUR MINIS UP MANY OF
THESE --
HOTELS ARE CHAINS THERE THEY ARE
PUBLICLY TRADED --
THEY HAVE LICENCES TO OPERATE IN
THE STATE A CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE
TO MEET CERTAIN HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS --
THIS COULD BE PART OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
I MEAN IT IS A SAFETY ISSUE FOR
THE WORKERS AND IT'S A HEALTH
ISSUE AS WELL.
AND SO MAYBE THROUGH THE IN THE
FOOD INDUSTRY IN THE HOTEL
INDUSTRY MAYBE THERE'S OTHER
WAYS TO APPROACH IT --
I MEAN IF YOU TRY TO LOOK LIKE
WITHOUT A CONTRACT.
IS THERE CERTAINLY ARE THAT WE
TO PUT ON THERE THAT WERE WERE
SOMEBODY FEELS THE PAIN TO NOT.
Q. COMMONSENSE LIES.
WELL I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT
THE REGISTRY BILL DOES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IF IT
REQUIRES AN EMPLOYER THEY EVERY
JANITORIAL CONTRACTOR HAS TO
BASICALLY HAS TO REGISTER.
AND THEN YOU'RE SUBJECT TO ALL
OF THESE REQUIREMENTS WHICH
INCLUDES THIS ADDITIONAL SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING AND IF YOU
DON'T REGISTER OR YOU DON'T
COMPLETE THE TRAINING OR YOU
DON'T COMPLETE ANY OF THE OTHER
REQUIREMENTS.
THEN YOU WOULD YOU WOULD LOSE
BASICALLY YOUR LICENSE AND YOUR
ABILITY SO EVERY TIME YOU HAVE
TO RE REGISTER YOU HAVE TO
SUBMIT INFORMATION TO THE STATE.
SO MAYBE SOMETHING ALONG THE
LINES OF THAT BUT TAYLOR TO A
DIFFERENT INDUSTRY THAT'S
RELATED.
TO IN OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU
HAVE BUT I THINK NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IS IS IS ONE MODEL
AND WE TOOK IT FOR A STATE
CONTRACTORS.
SUPPORT SO IT'S WE DEFINITELY
HAD IT -- IN
LA BEFORE AND I THINK WHERE NOW
TRYING TO ESTABLISH ONE FOR
PORTRAIT DRIVERS AS WELL SO.
MAYBE IT IS A WAY FOR THE FUTURE
THAT -- I
JUST WANT I I I I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT A LOT OF THESE
HOTELS ARE OWNED BY PRIVATE
EQUITY FIRMS THAT ARE.
LOW'S NNST SEE I HAVE TO SAY
BEFORE YOU DID IT YOU KNOW THAT
OUR CALPERS HAS INVESTED IN SO
THE POWER OF THE DOLLAR GO AHEAD
MONEY LENNY YOU KNOW THIS FAR
BETTER THAN I KNOW I YOU YOU HIT
IT ON ON THE NOSE --
WE HAVE COMPANIES PRIVATE EQUITY
COMPANIES.
THAT ARE BENEFITING FROM OUR
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND THEY COULD IN ONE FELL SWOOP.
THEY COULD MAKE A DECISION THAT
ANY COMPANY THEY OWN.
AND THAT WE ARE BENEFITING.
WOULD HAVE WOULD STOP THE
HARASSMENT PERIOD.
AND IF THEY DON'T THEN THEY
DON'T BENEFIT FROM MY TAX
DOLLARS --
SO THEY CONTINUE TO GO ALONG IT.
ENOUGH IT DOESN'T HIT HARD IN
THE POCKETBOOK THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO STOP UNLESS THERE IS
SOMETHING OF EQUAL POWER.
SO I THINK THAT'S A ANOTHER WAY
OF HOW THESE PRIVATE EQUITY
COMPANIES ARE FUNCTIONING WITH
OUR TAX DOLLARS.
WE NEED TO BE PUT ON HOLD --
I WONDERED JUST COMMENT ON KATHY
I APPRECIATE WHAT THE THE DTV
ROB FORD.
AND I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU
MORE ABOUT ENFORCEMENT POLICY.
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE NOW
FOR TWO YEARS AND I EXPRESSED MY
FRUSTRATION IS THAT.
ARE THE POLICY THAT WE'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER ARE WE
IMPLEMENTING IT AS WE WERE
HOPING ASSEMBLY EMPLOYMENT.
ARE WE DOING THE OVERSIGHT THAT
WE NEED TO DO ON IT.
AND SO I'M TURNING THE TABLES TO
US POLICIES THAT WE BILL PUT
TOGETHER WE SHOULD TEST AND
CHECK AND SEE IF THE WORKING
CORRECTLY.
ME THINK OF THINGS SOME SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT DO WE
NEED TO CHANGE SOME OF THOSE DO
THEY MEET UP UPDATING --
THOSE ARE SOME OF MY
FRUSTRATIONS I HAVEN'T WHEN.
POLICIES OLD WE DON'T GO BACK IN
AND IT MIGHT JUST NEEDED REAL
EASY TO TWEAK THE CHANGES ALL
THIS VERY EASILY --
RENDON THE VISION AND I THINK
SOMETIMES WE GET IN THIS WHOLE
WORKING AT THE CAPITOL AND WE
DON'T REALIZE THAT'S WHY I'M
HERE TODAY IS THAT.
HEARING A WHOLE NOTHER SIDE THAT
I HADN'T THOUGHT ABOUT I THINK
WE ALL NEED TO DO THAT.
UP A PRIOR PRIMARILY IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE THE
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE
[INAUDIBLE]
ARE WORKING.
AND MAKING SURE THE FOLLOW UP
WITH THOSE THAT AGENCIES ARE
THEY DOING THEIR JOB BECAUSE I
HAD A TERRIBLE SITUATION THAT
I'M WORKING ON YOU KNOW THE BILL
WAS.
THE HEALTH CARE DIVISION AND WE
FOUND OUT DATA WAS GOING TO
MANAGE HEALTH CARE.
AND IT'S SAD.
AND IT HAS DONE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
AND SO I THINK WE ALL SHOULD
PROBABLY LOOK AT SOME OF THE
POLICIES WERE INTERESTED IN AND
SEEING ISN'T ALREADY THERE AND
HOW CAN WE MAKE THAT BETTER OR
ELSE WHAT POLICIES WE DO DESIGN.
ARE PUT TOGETHER IS A WE FOLLOW
THROUGH I MEAN FROM YOU WERE
LUCKY WE'RE ALL HERE.
FOR POTENTIALLY TWELVE YEARS AND
YOU CAN DO APOLLO THE GOOD
POLICY IN THAT WHERE A PERIOD OF
TIME WE CAN IMPLEMENT THAT
POLICY WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THAT.
IF IT NEEDS AMENDMENTS AND
CHANGES WE CAN DO THAT SO I I I
SAY TO ALL OF US LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING.
IS REALLY WHAT IT WAS SUPPOSED
TO DO AND IF SOMETHING IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT MIGHT
NEED TO BE CHANGED [INAUDIBLE]
UPDATED SO.
I APPRECIATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR DISSIPATION ALBEIT.
YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS WAS --
EXTREMELY ENLIGHTENING I'VE BEEN
IN THE LEGISLATURE FOR JUST OVER
A MONTH NOW AND THIS IS NOT AN
AREA WHERE I HAVE TO TAKE EXPERT.
THIS WAS A VERY VERY VERY EYE
OPENING --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MON REALLY I
ASK IS AT THE HEART OF MY
QUESTION WHICH WAS ABOUT
ENFORCEMENT IN IN FRANKLY
SHOCKING TO ME THAT THERE'S ONLY
A PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT WOULD BE
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN ENFORCING --
I ALSO WANTED TO SAY MARINO LAYA --
I WAS STRUCK BY YOUR COMMENTS
BECAUSE I WAS TRYING MY
COLLEAGUE HERE --
I WAS TAKING NOTES REFLECTING ON
WHAT SOME OF THE WOMEN IN OUR
FIRST PANELIST SAID IN THE FIRST
THING I WROTE DOWN WAS POWER
IMBALANCE.
IT'S SAY TO ME THE REAL QUESTION
IS HOW DO WE SHIFT THAT POWER
BALANCE AND WHAT CAN WE DO S.
LEGISLATORS WHETHER THROUGH ITS.
OUR INFLUENCE ALL OVER THE LEGAL
PROP.
OR ANYTHING ELSE THAT I DO A
CHEF THAT PARAMOUNT'S AYE TWO
QUESTIONS --
AND I APOLOGIZE ONE OF THEM MAY
BE VERY DOWN THIS IS AN AREA I
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF EXPERTISE
AND ONE IS --
JUST THINKING ABOUT THE IDEA OF
REPEAT OFFENDERS --
AYE I'M ASSUMING THAT IT'S TRUE
THAT THERE A LOT OF INDIVIDUAL
REPEAT OFFENDERS FOR US THE
ABOUT THAT ALSO IN THE CORPORATE
SENSE AND WONDERING IF WE HAVE
ANY DATA ON THAT I KNOW A LOT OF
THIS MAY BE DIFFICULT TO FIND.
BUT PERHAPS THERE'S ONE WAY FOR
THE GOVERNMENT TO BE INVOLVED.
A TARGET BAD ACTORS WHERE
THERE'S REPEAT OFFENDERS IN THE
CORPORATE SENSE MAYBE YOU HAVE
PARTICULAR CORPORATIONS ARE
BUSINESSES WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND INDUSTRIES BUT
CORPORATIONS ARE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE BAD ACTORS.
THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN LOOK OKAY
THERE HAS BEEN A SERIES OF
OFFENSES THERE'S A THAT A
CULTURE HERE THAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE AND THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
STEP AND I'M IN THE SECOND WAS
JUST A MORE NARROW POINT --
THINKING ABOUT WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO HAD SAID --
MAYBE WE OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT
REQUIRED TO MEET WE DO THIS
ALREADY --
BUSINESSES THAT OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA PUT IN THEIR
CORPORATE FILINGS THE WAY IN
WHICH THEY COMPLY WITH --
SEXUAL HARASSMENT --
AND AND LAWS OF WHAT THEIR
POLICIES ARE WHAT THEY'RE DOING
TO PREVENT SEXUAL RATS BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY ANYTHING THAT THEY PUT
IN THOSE FILINGS --
YOU TO PUT THEM AT JEOPARDY AND
THAT WHAT WILL HOLD THEM TO TO
WHAT THEIR SANK SO THAT WAS
ANOTHER IDEA.
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME MOVEMENT AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO REQUIRE --
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO I BELIEVE IF
YOU'RE A PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANY
REPORTING LAWSUITS THAT THE
CORPORATION IS FACING.
AND SO IF THERE ARE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT LAWSUITS EVEN IN
PROCESS NOT NECESSARILY --
COMPLETED UMPIRE SEXUAL
DISCRIMINATION LAWSUITS --
THE WHOLE FOX NEWS OPERATION
ENDED UP WITH THE IT WAS A NIGHT.
NINETY MILLION IT MIGHT BE MORE --
PENALTY --
BECAUSE THEY HAD DEFRAUDED THEIR
INVESTORS BY NOT REVEALING THE
EXTENT OF THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND ASSAULT PROBLEMS --
IN THAT NEWS ORGANIZATION THAT
COST THEM HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN PAYOUTS AND BY NOT
REVEALING THAT YOU WERE
DEFRAUDING YOUR INVESTORS.
SO THERE MAY BE A ROLE FOR
CALIFORNIA --
TO PLAY IN THAT FOR ANY PUBLICLY
TRADED COMPANIES IT'S EITHER
REGISTERED HERE THAT IS DOING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE.
OR IS CERTAINLY A CONTRACTOR OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WITHOUT I THINK WERE RIGHT AT
OUR TIME SO I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE PANELISTS I ONE THINK THE
WORKERS WHO CAME OUT TO TIGHTEN
AND REALLY SET THE STAGE SO THAT
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE POLICY.
WE WE ARE GOING ALLOW --
PUBLIC COMMENT WE ARE RIGHT.
AND AND SO WE WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT WE WE GIVE PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY IF THERE IS A ONE
MINUTE.
PUBLIC COMMENT THOUGHTS.
ISSUE.
THAT SOMEBODY WANTS TO BRING
FORD PLEASE COME UP YES.
AND WHEN DOES MICROPHONE WORK
OVER THERE [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU [INAUDIBLE]
IT WOULDN'T.
MY NAME ITS WEATHER PICKING AND
WERE FOR FINANCES NUMBER THEY'LL.
AND THIS IS MY WILL WORK IF THAT
IS SEAT THAT.
NC SEEMS SHE CAN'T TELL WHAT
CABINET TO CARE I'M GOING.
TO OKAY IMPERATIVE DOESN'T
SIXTEEN BIT IS NOT THAT EASY
THEN ANOTHER WOMAN WHO WORKED IN
MY IN THE OLD THAT RENDON'S OF
NUMBERS AT THE END OF TIME A
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER HAVE
AS A SUPERVISOR.
COULD THEY REPORTED SIX ONLY
ARREST ME A RESIDENT.
INCLUDED TO RETALIATE AGAINST
ANYONE WHO REPORTED HIS CONDUCT.
THAT IS THE THEN MICHAEL WORKING
OF THE EMPIRE ALONSO HE IS FOR
US ALL ABOUT EIGHTY SIX ONE BODY
SIX ONE ARREST MEANT.
IN GENDER DISCRIMINATION AMONG
OTHER CAUSES.
WELL THE I TUNES [INAUDIBLE]
ACCORDING.
COURT RECORDS THE PARTIES
SETTLED THEIR LAWSUIT LAST YEAR.
BUT IT STANDS OF THE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT ARE NOT COOLEY.
IN SCENES THAT ISSUE THAT HAS
NOT BEEN ABLE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
I HAVE TO ASSUME ASSUME THAT
THAT IS A SILENCE LAOS.
IN THIS SEVEN AND LEAN AND MEAN
IN.
NEEDED THAT A STEEP NOT IN MY
OTHER COWORKER ARE STILL IN THE
RAIN AND SINCE.
BUT THE IRANIANS IS CONTINUE TO
EMPLOY THEM IN WHY RICE THING.
I DON'T THE WOMAN SHE WOULD BE
FORCED TO STAY QUIET ABOUT THAT
EXPERIENCE.
YOU SIGNED THAT WE PUT ON INTO
SILENCE TELLS [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT ANYONE WANTED AND
IF NOT I'LL JUST --
YOU WOULD LIKE TO IT AT DOES
ANYBODY.
A FINAL THOUGHTS.
I WANT TO THANK YOU WHILE I
THINK BY LEGISLATORS CAME AS FAR
AS NAPA WELL WINTERS --
ALL OF IT LA AREA SANTA BARBARA
AND ORANGE COUNTY TO HEAR THIS
AND AND HOPEFULLY TOGETHER --
THROUGH THESE NEXT FEW YEARS
WILL CONTINUE TO TO KEEP THIS
HIGHLIGHTED WITH OUR FRIENDS WHO
HAVE THE ATTENTION OF THE MEDIA --
AND AND HELPING US CAME OUT TO
ENSURE THAT ALL WORKERS ARE ARE
SAFE IT WORKS SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR COMING OUT